[Musique]
eric sadin bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view est ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement donc
deux ans plus tard à nouveau jeu mais je
veux plier à cet exercice
assez délicat de décliner moi même mon
identité et mes fonctions donc je suis
eric sadin je suis écrivain et
philosophe
et j'explore au travers de la fiction et
plus encore de la théorie depuis une
quinzaine d'années et précision depuis
une dizaine d'années la nature des
technologies numériques et l'impact sur
nos existences individuelles et
collectives mais mes petits distinguo
quand je lui dis
je suis écrivain et philosophe
les journées font que 24 heures les
derniers bouquins que j'ai subie j'ai
fait pareil c'était des livres de
théorie j'ai une fiction
dans les tiroirs que je vais publier
année prochaine mais de plus en plus je
tends vers ce que j'appelle une
littérature théorique c'est à dire de
plus en plus j'essaie de donner une 21e
une vanité rares à mes écrits théoriques
et quand je dis depuis depuis 15 ans
justice explore des technologies
numériques et l'infraction d existence
peut-être que des personnes ne s'y
attendent pas ce soir
après dix années particulier les années
2010 d'études
assidu de deux livres publiés tous les
ans et demi tous les deux ans où j'ai à
mon sens un peu fait le tour d'une
certaine question il est temps pour moi
à mon sens c'est ce que je fais là dans
une nouvelle publication
d'explorer les technologies numériques à
nouveaux frais non par d'après les
rouages économiques et les des terminaux
où les la collusion avec les politiques
ou l'encadrement de plus en plus serré
de nos existences mais au prisme de nos
propres usages et de savoirs et de j'en
suis arrivée je pense que nous allons
beaucoup parlé de cela ce soir comment
finalement
comment nous en sommes arrivés à être
prise au piège nous même d'un certain
environnement techno économique qui
s'est mise en place alors vont voler ma
première question
comment on en est arrivé à être à se
faire déposséder pratiquement nos
propres existences
comment on s'est coulé dans ce ronron
quotidien
toxiques toxiques
nous vivons un moment d'histoire un
moment de de notre existence de nos
existences on société où on sent bien
quelque chose qui a varié coire on vit
un moment de d'extrême crispation de la
société de brutalisation croissante des
rapports humains de
deux difficultés de rejet d'autrui
cela se fait sur une fonce tout cela
s'opère et on a l'impression que ça ne
cesse de s'aggraver tous les jours on
voit des événements ce 10 mai et qu'est
ce qui nous arrive qu est ce qui nous
est arrivé
qu'est ce qui nous est arrivé pour qu'on
arrive plus à 100 ans pour que chacun
fait en tant fait pour faire prévaloir
ses propres sentiments sa propre parole
d'événements pardon des exemples des
visages sais pas je pense par exemple à
la parole d'eric zemmour il ya trois
jours il ya quatre jours tous les jours
il ya des choses quoi toujours il ya des
choses qui confirme l'extrême
brutalisation de la société alors un des
indes est
un défi que je me suis lancée parce que
il faut que je dise une chose sky en
préambule parce que la dernière fois bon
je garde un très bon souvenir du moment
que nous avions passé ensemble et je
pense que ça a eu un bel écho auprès de
youtube vraiment très bon
des personnes m'ont dit peut-être à
raison mais c'est je vais m'expliquer
pourquoi en préambule un
que je citais peut-être un peu trop mon
livre de l'époque telle intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui siècle il se
trouve que moi je te l'aï dit tout à
l'heure au sky c'est que moi dès que je
publie un livre et quand j'en parle
pendant les mois qui viennent après je
me tais je ne suis pas du genre à aller
sur les plateaux et adélie mon avis
surtout notre dame qui brûlent donner
votre avis non ça je m'y refuse en
revanche je travaille donc mans
2 en général sur des enjeux et que je
mûris qui nourrissent une parole et un
truc à des positions que j'espère
informer puis ça d'un objet d'un nouveau
léger vent d'une publication
c'est synthétiser qui est le résultat
des analyses qui est qui se sont
déployés dans le temps là je publie un
nouveau livre c'est comme ça on se
retrouve à ce moment là où s'était
proposée depuis plusieurs depuis
plusieurs mois et je prie d'excuser en
tout cas les personnes que ça dérange si
je vais parler de mon livre parce que
c'est le résultat de recherches et de
choses que je vais dire la non pas pour
faire la promo de moi même il ya
plusieurs choses qui sont prévues dans
les semaines qui viennent ce n'est pas
l'enjeu on s'est dit que c'était bon
moment pour que je reparle ici ici
ensemble alors
j'en suis arrivé à
me dire depuis plusieurs années il faut
tenter de saisir la substance
propre de notre temps
ce que je pense et nous savons plus ou
moins tous que c'est une des choses
probablement les plus difficiles de
saisir l'esprit d'une époque de saisir
les choses au moment même où elles ont
lieu c'est extrêmement difficile parce
qu on est tout le temps pris dans les
fluides de l'actualité finalement
finalement le temps réel qui regardaient
des instruments techniques moi je pense
qu'elles se sont maintenant en ce
temps-là cette temporalité quand ça
regarde des instruments techniques bon
quand ça 96 khz et commence à être
elle-même imprimé par cette temporalité
là on puisse dire qu'il ya quelque chose
à la fois comme une cicatrisation la
société le commentaire en direct
l'impossible en direct de
continuellement réagir relativement aux
flux des eaux fudo fut des choses et
donc je me suis proposé de du diagnostic
et ce moment extrêmement troublant de
notre histoire bouzigues est absolument
m'agace esprit du temps l'esprit d'une
époque parce que moi l'inquiétude c'est
pas une notion qui me fait beaucoup
travailler mais le fait de saisir qu'il
y a des indices de plus en plus prégnant
nombre qui s'aggrave qui ne cessent de
se multiplier et qui témoigne de risque
qui nous regardent tous ça il fallait
que je me confronte en tout cas moi même
personnellement à l'intérieur de ma
logique de recherche à c'est une sorte
de préambule que je fais le métier est
important et
nous en sommes tous arrivés à c'est le
moment que nous vivons
au constat de l'échec de politique de
plus en plus débridée à l'oeuvre depuis
une quarantaine d'années en gros depuis
l'alternance libéral des années 80 nous
en sommes arrivés au constat et moi j'en
suis arrivée je vais déployer cela que
le pacte de confiance n'existe plus
entre les individus et la parole
politique quelle qu'elle soit c'est
extrêmement important quelle qu'elle
soit même de la part des armées depuis
très peu de temps de la part de partis
dits anti système et
d'où je viens moi l'analyse des
technologies numériques
je me suis dit que nos usages des
technologies numériques de pratique de
plus en plus assidus depuis une
vingtaine d'années plus encore depuis
une dizaine d'années au prisme de deux
nouvelles interfaces de nouveaux
protocoles de nouveau le système n'ont
fait je vais pas dire aggravé n'ont fait
que intensifiés cet état des choses qui
à mon sens je vais m'expliquer au fur et
à mesure nous mène à un échec à des as
des as des effets d'impuissance et pour
terminer sur ce premier moment nous ne
cessons
d'être à la fois de désorienter par set
cette situation d'époque j'avais été
marqué
benjamin biolay très sympathique j'ai
été marqué par la une de télérama l'été
dernier le monde est devenu fou
il ya quelque chose comme ça que tout le
monde ressent où qu'ils soient on est
devenus faut il ya quelque chose voilà
je pense qu'on peut pas dire de façon
plus plus simple peut-être même famille
a quelque chose à vriller quelques euros
on ne maîtrise plus comme le co vie il
ya quelque chose qui tient qui nous a
dépossédé notre capacité de maîtrise il
ya quelque chose qui est dans le cours
de nos existences
collectives mais aussi individuelles
par les choses qui relèvent de la
désorientation alors il s'est passé
quelque chose vous l'avez remarqué
je suppose que les membres de la
communauté sikhe review c'est qu'ils ne
regardent l'on remarqué aussi depuis une
dizaine d'années on ne cesse d'évoquer
pour comprendre la substance du temps un
supposé retour des populismes
aujourd'hui en 2015 2020 alors il ya eu
des monceaux d'ouvragé vous souvenez
vous l'avez relevé relativement à ce
phénomène certains sont même allés jusqu
à opérer des rapprochements quasi
systématique je ne décide pas ne pas le
citer je ne suis pas je veux dire de mal
de personnes là c'est pas l'enjeu
d'opérer des rapprochements systématique
entre les années 30 la fin d année 2010
selon des procédés qui à mon sens le
rajoute ne font que rajouter à la
confusion parce que je les dis on a du
mal à saisir ce qui se joue et qui
empêche de saisir la la substance
spécifique de notre époque et pour
terminer sur cela sky je pense pour ma
part que nous n'avons aucune manière à
faire un retour des populistes ou à un
moment populiste de notre histoire mais
nous avons faire et nous l'avons pas vu
venir
et c'est ce que j'ai analysé dans mon
nouvel ouvrage voyage en parle là parce
que pas pour faire la promo mais parce
que je dois préciser de quoi il s'agit
nous avons affaire à l'avènement d'une
nouvelle condition de l'individu
contemporain d'une nouvelle condition de
nous-mêmes je vais m'expliquer alors que
les structures politiques l'ordre
général en place eux mêmes sont restés
dans les grands pour leurs grandes
lignes à l'identique et ça crée une
nouvelle torsion dont il faut saisir la
nature et des effets induits est ce que
vous avez peur pour vous pour l'avenir
est ce que vous avez des projets en
analysant l'air du temps
l'esprit du temps est ce que vous prenez
des frissons
extrapoler cette situation a anticipé
cette situation et si oui quels sont vos
mécanismes de défense pour après
je dirais de choses sur sa le mécanisme
de défense j'en ai
c'est l'analyse
écriture
l'offre aux personnes qui souhaitent
recevoir cela de
d'analysé de et aussi de
pas de schéma d'action d'horizon
d'action nous allons en parler il y as
par rapport à l'inquiétude je veux dire
autrement les choses il ya une
expérience subjective singulière
peut-être tout le monde a vécu
probablement tout le monde a vécu
moi j'aime bien en général je suis
souvent enfermé à la maison en semaine
parce que je travaille sur mes ouvrages
et je lui julie beaucoup les week-ends
j'aime bien me balader dans paris elle
voir des expos et en librairie et j'ai
remarqué ça n'allait croissance et dix
dernières années que plus je marchais de
là où j'habite vers le marais en général
je prenais du samedi que j'aime bien
plus j'ai assisté à des effets de
brutalisation des chocs récurrent dans
les espaces publics des gens qui seront
les personnes qui se rendent dans des
paroles des invectives et cela c'est pas
possible ne pas être troublé de cela de
voir ses effets de brutalisation de
crispation et j'en suis arrivée là jeudi
une chose que je comptais dire à la fin
que je l'aï dit dès maintenant
qu'on a été fracassée
on est fracassée qu'est ce que ça veut
dire on ne fera qu'un seul c'est à dire
que tous les effets de plus en plus
délétère du néolibéralisme sur nos
existences
quand j sur nos existences ses avants en
premier lieu on en avait parlé la
dernière fois à ascari ensemble dans le
monde du travail
c'est dans le monde de nos deux ans
société sert le recul des services
publics la mise en compétition de plus
en plus croissante entre personnes le
monde de l'éducation et difficultés dans
l'éducation l'aggravation des inégalités
nous avons été peu à peu sur noise mans
fracassé par une situation qui nous
déborder et on nous débordons nous a
rendus de plus en plus impuissante et
nous a donné le sentiment de cette
impuissance c'est très important cela
parce que l'industrie du numérique nous
allons probablement venir a eu l'extrême
génie le grand génie là encore on avait
parlé du génie de cette industrie de
nous offrir des sentiments ne donnant
l'illusion de pouvoir reprendre la main
c'est la plus on a été dépossédé plus on
est d'un cru pouvoir reprendre la main à
l'intérieur d'un écartèlement qui donc
il faut à la fois saisir la portée est
qui et qui a des conséquences délétères
que je vais décliner mais nous avons été
fracassées c'est à dire quand je dis
fracassé c'est pas seulement les corps
des gens vous disent elle établit de
robert lienhardt qui est allé voir dans
les usines dans les années soixante dix
comment ça se passait à la fin des
années 60 je crois c'est pas non plus la
condition ouvrière de simone veil décor
des corps qui sont abîmés unis bilité du
tout la pénibilité du travail
candy décor il ya les esprits
mais les esprits je pense que personne
n'est sorti indemme c'est ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui nous vivons un moment
où nos psys qu'est nos esprits nos
façons de vivre
nous sommes en a mais comme nous sommes
en année il ya la pulsion vivre la
pulsion d'existence on a envie de
continuer à exister mais on a du mal à
trouver les moyens alors alors on laisse
parler nos affects on utilise les
instruments à noeux à satiété wad
nauseam en vue de faire parler notre
trop-plein d'affect on peut le
comprendre mais nous sommes prêts à
casser alors ce que ce que je voudrais
envisager ce soir avec j'ai vu que tu me
voyez ce soir là du tout la défense
était tu toi que tu as pris de la
distance avec moi de ségou moi c'est
pour ça que tu toi si tu veux bien
puisque conclusion je ne fais pas ce
bois là
et donc
il ce que je vous dis voilà un moment
j'ai perdu mon fils il faudra bien que
et c'est ce que je vois là ce que je
voulais faire avec vous avec toi ce soir
et avec la communauté thing herviou
c'est de penser ensemble penser
comment dépasser comment dépasser nous
seuls notre plein d'affect légitime il y
a des plaies nous avons vu nous sommes
tous faits de pelé et à des blessures à
sont nombreuses à son même énorme
et nous les exprimer
il s'agit pas que dans l'expression
d'expressivité ce que je nomme les
plateformes d'expressivité entre autres
il va falloir engager l'action mais pour
cela il faut comprendre d'où nous venons
sky d'où nous venons il ya une histoire
c'est pour ça que je dis quand nous
sommes fracassé nous sommes le résultat
d'une histoire moi ce que j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait pour ce livre vert de
l'individu tian je suis désolé j'en
parle je suis en vala en amitié là ce
soir c'est pas pour vendre mon bouquin
je suis avec vous on ne voit là c'est
pour
la relative pour essayer de les saisir
ce qui nous arrive et pour ce qu'il
désire ce qui nous arrive nous sommes le
produit d'une situation d'une histoire à
ckoi notre histoire tu veux bien de
chant parle de skype c'est quoi notre
histoire nous sommes nous en tout cas on
va dire très largement en occident dans
les pays du nord
en europe aux états-unis les enfants les
fils des petits-fils les héritiers d'un
pacte politique
très identifié qui se nommait qui se
nomme à l'origine l'individualisme
libéral qui remonte à la fin du xviiie
siècle je suis pas faire tout l'histoire
toute l'histoire mais je vais dire à des
à des points pivots desquels nous venons
et qui remonte à la fin du xviie siècle
et notamment à john locke second
traitait du gouvernement et aux
le white beans en angleterre à la fin du
salon fera remonter loin fin du 10ème
ciel qui posait quoi ce pacte politique
c'est un pacte politique qui posait qu'
il fallait un peu éloigné il fallait
mettre à distance le principe
aristocratique du principe de la royauté
au profit d'un pacte qui favorisait la
liberté individuelle à l'intérieur d'un
souci de l'ensemble commun de la
cohésion générale
mais avec une nuance de taille de taille
qu'il faut rappeler qu'il faut souligner
immédiatement ses salles de
l'enrichissement personnel c'est ça
cette triple équation un donc aussi la
mise en compétition n'ont dit mon guide
mais implicite entre les êtres
c'est ce pacte de l'individualisme
libéral qui a été célébré au cours des
lumières au cours du xviiie siècle un
cette tension là dont on veut dire qu a
priori elle est très noble qui continue
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on va voir jusqu'où
je vais venir me dire un priori ce pacte
il est très très noble libertés
individuelles exercice de notre propre
jugement
manifestation de nos capacités
subjective individus sains manifestation
delà de la volonté de réaliser nos
propres désirs
ensemble commun qui soucie de la
meilleure cohésion et possibilités de
de plus en plus sans entrave de faire
valoir la possibilité de leur
relâchement de leur enrichissement
personnel et de la compétition de plus
en plus effrénée entre entre les êtres
xviiie siècle c'est ce modèle qui a été
célébrée travailler notamment notamment
france par condorcet ou sortir la
révolution française et au 19e siècle
c'est ce modèle qui a prévalu un
jefferson
1801 qu'ils disent est ce modèle là aux
états unis qui va déterminer la taille
visuels disponibles le la politique de
notre pays fondée sur l'initiative
individuelle et puis la puissance
publique et or est en france c'est ça
qui a prévalu or qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
que très vite ce modèle a généré
illégalité
paupérisation précarité
souffrant ce travail suffit devant les
romans sociaux dickens zola et tout ce
que tolstoï et balzac il ya eu d'autres
modèles qui ont prescrit qui ont écrit
qu'ils ont été théorisé je pense par
exemple au modèle socialiste
le modèle anarchiste proudhon et qui est
fondée sur la solidarité fondée sur la
mise en commun des ressources c'est ce
modèle qui revêtait une puissance
mobilisatrice et ça je vais en parler en
quelques mots énorme c'est sur cela que
j'ai travaillé un
un horizon mobilisateur
c'est à dire un impact politique qui à
la fois promet
la liberté de chacun
est le plus grand de la plus grande
cohésion sociale il est il a une
puissance de mobilisation et une
puissance de rêve qui est qui et j'ai
presque envie de dire quasi impasse est
imé presque a priori ko tous les autres
modèles quoi presque presque chauve qui
a eu voilà ce qu'on a dit quantité de
dérive j'ai presque envie de dire allez
était presque inscrits à la base ces
dérives mais ce qui casse qui est ce qui
caractérise cette histoire de
l'individualisme libéral qui après
devenu ce qui a été nommé
l'individualisme démocratique c'est
qu'il a été constamment remis sur le
chantier et là je viens notre histoire
très récente sky il a été très vite
remis sur le chantier où il était
entendu qu'il ya eu des dérives qui est
donc les chantres on dit il ya eu plein
de résultats probants je pense par
exemple au second empire un les les
expositions universelles c'était quoi
c'était de montrer la splendeur de ce
modèle politique 1 mais qui est qui
masquait c'est comme les stades au qatar
la splendeur des stades et puis il ya
tous les morts philippins et tout est le
bac le bac aussi simple
et donc ce
modèle là il a j'ai presque envie dit
réprouver des résultats supposé en
termes de réalisations industrielles est
un très très grand nombre une grande
majorité j'ai presque envie de dire 4 1
10% des personnes ont vécu la souffrance
des souffrances induite par ce modèle
est donc il a toujours été remise sur le
chantier en disant il ya eu trop de
dérives
c'est à l'e3 loin et on reprend c'est
très important ce que je dis pas ce
qu'on va voir comment nous en avons vécu
que ça c'est à dire on va re on va re si
on va corriger les choses et puis à
nouveau ça il ya des effets
déliquescence et il ya un moment
pivot décisif dans notre histoire
commune celle de l'après guerre ses
pivots c'est décisive dire qu'après
toutes les souffrances endurées endurées
au cours de du second conflit mondial il
y a dans les grands de dans les grandes
démocraties ou dans les grandes sociétés
plus ou moins social libéral dans les
pays du nord
se sont ont été mises en place des
mécanismes qui délibérément j'ai presque
envie de dire énergiquement très
volontairement on dit on maintient ce
pacte après les dérives
des politiques nazis ou et ou après
certains ont dit déjà le les tôles et
socio politique était pas considéré
comme un modèle
convenable pour certains été formulée
ainsi les choses au sortir de la guerre
ce modèle il a de la valeur il faut
jusque et redonner corps pour lui
redonner sa plume substance il faut lui
redonner sa puissance de mobilisation et
près son principe d'espérance le conseil
national de la résistance en 44 qui au
moment même à la fin à la fin du conflit
où les choses étaient quasi joué on dit
mécanismes de solidarité c'est le coeur
de ce qui est de ce qui constitue notre
société bayer bien déjà le lien qu'on
fait avec notre président avec notre
présent mécanismes de solidarité
sécurité sociales indemnités chômage de
chômage retraite pareils aux états unis
en angleterre ce que c'est magnifique
tout le monde le sait mais il faut le
redire
le nom du programme qui a été
rédigé par le conseil national de la
résistance c'est ce qu'a vu le nom du
programme ouais je me rappelle juste
d'une vidéo les joueurs eux les jours
heureux et chanceux je vous conseille de
regarder je conseille la communauté une
vidéo du conseil national de la
résistance qui dit résister c'est créer
créer c'est résister mais ça ne l'est
pas et je connais la formule ça se
trouve
je pense aussi point fondamental la même
année la déclaration dite de philadephie
en 1944 qui a qui a
rassembler toutes les personnes
impliquées dans le monde du travail et
qui a affirmé la priorité du respect de
l'intégrité de la dignité humaine et de
lier de façon indissociable les
questions économiques et sociales donc
ça c'est le sait le socle de ce qui
s'est passé au sortir de la guerre s'est
bâti des voyous alors c'est pas
seulement le socle c'était le début de
politique keynésienne c'est à dire que
la puissance publique les politiques le
pacte commun était celui d'un
interventionnisme en vue d'assurer notre
meilleur bien commun là nous sommes bien
commun dont nous avons beaucoup parlé
depuis une dizaine d'années dans
floraison d'articles et de publication
ce d'autant que c'est notamment la
préservation de notre bien commun qui a
su qui a subi quantité d'assaut depuis
40 ans depuis une vingtaine d'années
encore plus depuis 10 ans
ce qu'il s'est passé c'est que au cours
des années 50 je vais pas le faire
maintenant très grand trait à l'histoire
et moi j'ai beaucoup aimé relire
mythologies de barthes quand vous voyez
bart à la foire de passe qui raconte à
la foire de paris on voit bien que ce
pacte aider à l'oeuvre c'est à dire les
gens qui rêvent devant la ds c'est très
très beau ses textes pour ceux qui n'ont
pas lu t on voit bien que c'est pas
seulement ils rêvent pas seulement
devant la ds de citroën ils sont ils
sont dans un moule d'un modèle politique
social économique
qui qui qui promet il suffit de se
mettre à la tâche
il est certes inégalitaire mais par le
travail on va pouvoir accéder à des
cadets des conditions d'existence
meilleur c'était ça le pacte est ce qui
a été nommé au cours de la décennie
suivante société lacoste société de
consommation c'est passablement société
de consommation le fait que les gens
consommaient c'est qu'est ce que ça veut
dire sur ce t2 consommation aujourd'hui
on peut l'entendre en 2020 c'est que eux
ont donné un nom à ce pacte qui avait
des valeurs dont on se disait on
consomme
on s'enrichit par le travail cercle
c'était déjà une dépolitisation des
existences qui avait tout de suite
souligné
marqueuses horkheimer et adorno il ya
quantité de corpus mais c'était ça c'est
à dire peut-être comme jamais ce qui a
été nommé le début des trente glorieuses
peut-être comme jamais l'adhésion à un
mythe l'ami de l'individualisme libéral
ce que j'ai décrit de fond c'est fini
voilà la croissance il ya une sorte
d'addiction
d'adhésion général et pia c'est pas bon
pour le micro ce que j'ai fait il ya un
moment il ya un moment pour les oreilles
de longer souci je vous prie plus qu'il
ya un moment
je tape dans les mains c'est pas pour
rien parce que là c'est une rupture
c'est une rupture quand je dis nous
sommes fracassé ses premiers moments de
moments nous avons été fracassées c'est
le début de la crise des années 70 des
mouvements d industrialisation
le chômage de masse que début des
délocalisations souple et rond lic le
choc prête pétrolier tu as bien raison
aux états unis ça a été terrible en
france en europe et là il ya eu le
premier moment où
les personnes se sont dit que quelque
chose comme le modèle politique sociale
il est fragile il ne tient plus ses
promesses notamment la pénibilité du
travail dans tu est que la promesse
d'enrichissement d'amélioration
régulière ça commençait à
à devenir plus compliqué plus ardue à
réaliser et même a été vécue et puis
nous sommes en france il ya un premier
mois je pensais notre premier
traumatisme
je vais vous raconter tout à l'heure une
petite anecdocte relativement à ça il ya
un premier un traumatisme
parce que je crois j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur la mémoire des peuples
la mémoire des peuples allez allez allez
allez parfois discrète les choses se
transmettent de génération en génération
sur le terme épigénétiques ou sur le
thème culturel les deux et culturales et
culturelles et même j'ai presque envie
de dire intime c'est à dire les les
souffrances de nos grands parents on les
connais les souffrances de nos parents
on les connaît quand elles
s'additionnent à nos propres souffrances
ça crée un composé et l'agent on va
revenir bientôt au coeur de notre
histoire audience oh non non non on n'en
peut plus par effet d'accumulation parce
que le premier choc comprenez quand on
vit le choc des délocalisations tout ce
qu'on a dit là sur les années 70 ok il
ya eu des manifestations il ya eu des
sarts tombe puis quand il ya un deuxième
choc ça se transmet il arrivé à un
moment c'est les corps on n'a pas les
décors les cités mais aussi la mémoire
collective même si la mémoire par delà
les générations où là il ya quelque
chose qui se manie verdi c'est terminé
c'est le coeur c'est un des coeurs de
ceux dont je voulais parler avec vous ce
soir notamment liés comment cela
s'articule à usage des technologies
numériques depuis une vingtaine d'années
c'est terminé et il ya eu mon premier
moment pivot en tout cas en france il a
été vécu ailleurs je pense à margaret
thatcher en 79 de l'élection de
mitterrand qui a laissé croire qui a
laissé supposer pas croire qu'il
laissait supposer est un moment de rêve
comme ça de tous les cas de l'espoir
collectif qu'à nouveau la question
sociale l'equilibre le pacte allait
pouvoir être instauré et deux ans plus
tard après d'audacieuses réforme
deux ans plus tard ce pack
le tournant de la alors là ça a été
terrible ça a été terrible c'est à dire
même du camp supposé prémunir nous
prémunir de talent de telles dérives
c'est le tournant néolibéral qui a eu
lieu à ce moment là un jeu rappelle de
tout le monde connaît cette histoire me
thatcher en 79 reagan en 80 tournant de
la rigueur en 83 et il ya eu avant les
chicago boys sont 73 au chili après le
coup d'état de pinochet donc là et hayek
prix nobel entre guillemets
d'économie enfin que les pas du tout à
un prix nobel d'économie c'est autre
chose et prix de ces prix de la banque
de suède donc déjà s'est dit les choses
j'ai rien contre la banque de suède il
faut replacer ces pâles prix nobel c'est
une parenthèse jours à l'ambassade de
suède ou passage très bien
donc hayek en 74 à dire que les retours
de politiques néolibérales dans l'esprit
des politiques en gros les politiques
keynésiennes ont échoué à interpréter à
gérer la situation retour d'hayek
thatcher reagan mitterrand est contre ça
rit gaz ou les choux et
les politiques sociales et ben ils ont
échoué à la raison de plein de moi je te
propose de dérouler l'histoire sky mais
elles ont échoué d'abord parce que parce
que
c'est pareil pour l'industrie numérique
j'en ai beaucoup parlé de cela parce que
le monde économique nous allons nous le
savons
non seulement n'en fait qu'à sa tête
mais d'une puissance dont nous avons vu
à quel point je vais de redon dont il
est dit des puissances d'ailleurs il est
pas cuit sans imposer ses dogmes il est
puissant dans les faits il est puissant
à propager des discours je vais parler
des discours à nouveau comme nous en
avons parlé il ya deux ans donc ça a été
un choc terrible
et puis je vais pas faire toute
l'histoire
il y avait eu un deuxième choc en tout
cas pour nous en france qui a été
aussi des lecteurs voire plus alors
l'achat d'un seul coup je fais un saut
historique pour qu'on vienne un peu au
coeur de notre présence si tu es
d'accord
il ya eu l'élection
du 2 d'un deuxième président dit on
nouvel hymne est socialiste de la vème
république françois hollande en 2007
en 2012 pardon jeudi 2016 parce que je
pense à la
loi travaille depuis sept se fait sans
fin
2012 donc après sarkozy s'est dit bon à
nouveau 80 à peu près avec moins de
moins d'illusions
et a à nouveau c'est le choc à nouveau
on va reprendre le contrat social à
nouveaux frais comme je spa en 97 1 sauf
que les politiques sociales libérales
ont 90 partir de 97 fraudeurs tony blair
bill clinton et à ce moment social
libéral afin d' histoire fukuyama je
fais tout de suite remonter en arrière
30 secondes en réalité c'était la porte
ouverte au monde au monde économique et
de monde de l'industrie quand je dis
industrie c'est à dire avec tout tous
les dogmes et tous les modes d'existence
et surtout de travail qu'ils ont imposé
un pays notamment à poser de l'industrie
numérique ou cours pensez à la fin des
années 90 et au cours des années 2010
jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc là encore il ya
eu l'idée on remet le pacte social
libéral enfin le pack de
l'individualisme démocratique
sur le chantier on va à nouveau corrigé
les choses mesdames et messieurs chers
peuple nous allons à nouveau quand à
nouveau savry alors élu en 2012
et à nouveau on vérifie quoi que
hollande thatcher c'est la même chose il
n'ya pourquoi je dis ça tina there is no
alternative et hollande qui à nouveau
mais c'est incroyable ce qui s'est passé
pour nous en france
c'est incroyable ce qui s'est passé
c'est à dire c'est peut-être aujourd'hui
qu'on comprend les effets et je vais
vous raconter petite anecdote de rejeter
18 de raconter parce que ça m'a beaucoup
marqué ça puis j'en reviens mais
pourquoi eric sadin parle de tout ça
alors qu'il nous parle de technologie
depuis dix ans depuis vingt quinze ans
maintenant on va comprendre comment il
faut articuler cela ça profite pour dire
que avance nos 2 avait sorti un bouquin
sur la surveillance en 2009
personne n'en parlait à la c'est ce jour
là où je t'ai repéré il continue moi je
te connaissais pas encore ce que
2009 soit une hausse globale j'ai pas le
temps de dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
la survie non seulement je vous avais
dit déjà la dernière émission
ce que visiblement on a beaucoup de
choses à se dire ce soir après deux ans
c'est pour ça que je viens pas tous les
six mois mois je viens quand j'ai
travaillé des choses c'est une
parenthèse que j'ai déjà dis donc
12 2012 des catcheurs hollande
terminaux internet et valse des dalles
is no alternative pas seulement ça axel
le maire qui aujourd'hui se rachète une
conscience french tech marchon tout ce
que j'ai raconté la dernière fois elle a
essayé elle a essayé ces battues bécue
le plan chiffrement au pardon pour le
chiffrement labsolu affaires l'envers
dans tous les sens mais elle est assez
bon au moins sur seine à issy bon je
suis plus sceptique que toi mais c'est
passé on va dire que ce n'est pas
l'enjeu du soir en tous les cas l'idée
c'était que l'industrie numérique
c'était plus que jamais à cette période
là aujourd'hui les choses sont
différentes en 2020 karl car nous vivons
une un moment d'une évolution
extrêmement rapides des mentalités 2015
2016 2020 sait pas exactement la même
chose c'est très important la vie test
d'évolution de mentalité ça c'est un
phénomène majeur contemporain majeur je
vais revenir à mes moutons sinon je suis
spécialiste des des parenthèses donc on
va se donc 2016 le travail
comme rislois travail là on s'est dit
c'est qui au long mais c'est quoi la
gauche c'est quoi le socialisme français
on a eu en a eu mitterrand la rigueur on
a eu chaud ce point c'était la politique
sociale libérale qui en réalité était un
fait le lit de toutes les politiques
néolibérales qui se sont qui sont
revenus par la fenêtre et encore avec
hollande alors je vous raconte en
quelques mots avant qu'on arrive au
coeur de notre présent
d'une anecdote que j'ai vécu dans l'est
dans l'est dans les locaux de chez
grasset donc quand j'ai signé les
services de presse pour pour mon livre
qui sort demain donc
un moment est venu
les menus mariska pas pour signer un de
ses livres chez grasset mais avant ça il
ya eu quelqu'un de la protection
rapprochée des ministres est quelqu'un
extrêmement sympathique de la police du
ministère de l'intérieur
qui voit mon bouquin qui miment c'est
quoi ce truc l'air de l'es18 iran la fin
d'un monde comme il dit c'est quoi ce
qui commence à voir le le sommaire new
la lave m'intéressait là je voyais bien
qu'il avait envie d'avoir le livre au
début je voulais pas lui offrir la fin
je vais vous faire mais c'est passe
alors de jeu et il me dit il voit les
chômeurs ingouvernabilité permanents
dont on va parler tout à l'heure si tu
es d'accord un point essentiel de notre
présent il voit quantité de choses il
dit mais monsieur
ce que vous ce que vous avez l'air de
décrire de ce que je comprends très
rapidement de ma vie tous les jours
alors non seulement ça mais il me dit
monsieur c'est pas ma croûte évidemment
que c'est le maquereau je vais pas citer
son nom puisqu'il est fonctionnaire dit
j'ai 37 ans de police mois méfie toi
parce qu'ils vont pouvoir leur trouver
la date est adorable et messieurs
d'ailleurs je vais gym à délétion
l'adresse mal mais comme je le contacte
parce qu'il faut le protéger impossible
ce qui menaçait un refus en web mais
metformine mais il n'a rien dit de mal
c'est surtout que c'est un sociologue
même quand il parlait j'ai dit monsieur
vous êtes un des plus vous êtes un
formidable sociologue tu te rends compte
qu'ils 37 ans de police parce que koné
sur la situation en france quelqu'un qui
à 37 ans police le sociologue de
toujours être sur le terrain exactement
le terrain on va en parler scary situé
tout à l'heure de ça suffit les paroles
de leur sol il faut qu'on parle du temps
ça suffit les par leur sol et de
l'industrie numérique et des politiques
et de tant de choses donc il voit le
truc qui me dit que ça vient ça vient
c'est pas macron ça vient de mitterrand
alors la place à avrillé dans ma tête il
me dit ça a bien de 83 je dis monsieur
il faut il faut qu'on prenne un verre
ensemble nous dit monsieur le tournant
de la rigueur ça a été terrible terrible
en termes de désillusions collective et
je lui montre l'extrait dans le bouquin
me dit je vous mets tellement
sympathique et pas seulement vous mais
tellement sympathique je vais profiter
du vous j'ai l'impression que j'ai
tellement pouvoir apprendre de vous
qu'on va prendre un verre il dit tenez
votre votre 4 je vais lire votre bouquin
on se voit quand vous bon donc ça dit
les choses ça dit des choses que même
quelqu'un qui a vécu comme tu dis sur le
terrain des souffrances car nous sommes
ses cartes quarante dernières années
n'ont pas été faites que de cela à bondy
mais elles ont été faites beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
souffrances que nous payons donc ça
constitue ce présent cette histoire nous
sommes le résultat de cette histoire
mais là pour rejoindre si je fais encore
la petite histoire en quelques mots
avant de venir à 2000 à octobre 2020 si
tu es d'accord et à ce que nous vivons à
des choses tu parlais inquiète non mais
c'est pas que ça m'inquiète ça ma lame
et à
des horizons qu'à ma propre mesure je
veux dessiner c'est pas des horizons
très très très ambitieux et c'est très
moderne est un bien des régions modeste
qui me semble pour le coup impératif ce
qu'il s'est passé c'est qu'on a parlé du
monde économique
ce qui s'est passé c'est que moi je
pense que on sous-estiment
le que jenny du monde économique le
génie de l'industrie de pas seulement là
de la silicon valley qui a été sortie de
l'acmé de sa mégalomanie peut-être on a
sous-estimé la puissance d'inventivité
la mégalomanie ou ne sous-estime
non mais c'est pas le coeur pour moi
pour moi c'est la puissance
d'inventivité c'est à dire tu connais
tout le monde connaît ce livre de nouvel
esprit du capitalisme
cas de polanski et capello où il analyse
comment au moment où par le recul du
principe de solidarité par le le le
refus dans le monde du travail de de
vouloir se plier à des normes
tropez dictée trop trop trop stricte et
toute la société dans son ensemble au
delà du monde de travail on est appelés
à la responsabilisation des individus à
la responsabilité qu'est ce que ça veut
dire la responsabilité
c'est à dire se prendre en charge
ne plus des sociologues comme à la rn
berg christopher lasch ou
ou des politiques qui ont analysé ça de
près et fo cause qu'il a appelé le ton
en prenant en entrepreneuriat de sa vie
un un moment là où il y avait moins de
le principe de solidarité était moins
l'oeuvre a pris le relais une sorte
d'idéologie de doxa j'ai presque envie
de dire de faciliter un d'outils qui
arrange et beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
monde
d'engager un auto entreprenariat de sa
vie alors il ya eu des cadres contraire
de contractuels à l'idée de il ya eu
l'idée aussi de délai aux risation du
talent des personnes dans le monde du
travail c'est ce sale l'addon par le
nouvel esprit du capitalisme
et puis il y eut
déjà par les souffrances tues parler de
pénibilité c'est un terme qu'on pourrait
utiliser à plusieurs échelles dans nos
sociétaires les écoles les gamins les
parents d'élèves les profs et ce qu'ils
vivent pas de la pénibilité on pourrait
presque l'extraire que du strict cadre
du monde du travail et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé je parlais de lipovetsky
peut-être que tout le monde ne connaît
pas c'est un sociologue intéressant ou
philosophes et plus je crois qu'il est
deux on les distingue où il pas toujours
très pertinent où il a parlé un moment
d'une ère du vide c'est un bouquin des
années 80 intéressant mais je crois que
c'était pas du tout une ère du vide
c'était l'idée que les gens qu'on
pensait pénibilité souffrance et qui a
eu un repli sur soi ce qu'on appelait
l'individualisation de la société
mais au même moment et individualisation
est aussi appel à la responsabilité et à
un moment cerner arrivés au fur et à
mesure du temps au fur et à mesure au
fil du temps à une extrême
appel à la responsabilité qui nous a un
peu la
fracasser à nouveau les
les psys qu'est et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le monde économique à suit
deux offrir déjà et là on commence à
approcher le coeur de la machine à
chiots offrir aux individus des outils
jeu presqu'envie dire donnant le
sentiment de pouvoir un peu se maîtriser
de trouver un peu des moments de
réjouissance des moments de confort qui
avait aussi pour certains
pour certains cas une valeur cathartique
alors je pense à quoi je pense par
exemple à cette individualisation de la
société 2c de s'extraire un peu de des
flux de plus en plus ardu de la société
au magnétoscope les années 80
l'individualisation des rapports au
programme du micro ondes et tout un
moment de pouvoir à son gré a selon ces
moments dans la famille dans le cercle
familial
hors de sa voiture
la personnalisation des produits
des radios libres plusieurs segments de
population pour les apparences et pour
les des apparences
ethnique ou culturelle des radios guerre
à toute une série de choses qu'il y ait
ou pire à des radios pirates les chaînes
câblées segmentation des cibles bref à
un moment ce
cette individualisation de la société
le monde
économique à l'intérieur de cet air du
temps a su donner des outils donnant à
chacun le moment l'occasion de
de d'un peu pouvoir autant qu'il le peut
pour chacun vivre d'existence à son
voile à son sens se réappropriant les
choses se sentir roi alors se sentir war
alors là c'est le sait le deuxième
moment de ce moment là moi j'aime bien
les signaux faibles du temps c'est pour
ça que j'aime beaucoup roland barthes
qui sur des chaussées qui était
sémiologue terre qu'elle analysait les
signes de l'époque
nike 88 la virgule
just do it c'est extraordinaire c'est
dans la continuité de cet appel à la
responsabilisation jeudi même dans mon
livre la virgule et comme un appel à
séquencer continuellement son existence
à la suite de quantité de virgule
appelant à témoigner de la
singularisation de son existence mais
mais
il s'est passé
exactement même moment à la fin milieu
mais plutôt vers les années 96 90 plus
encore 97 98 deux événements
techno-économique
sociaux civilisationnel aujourd'hui on
va le dire décisif qui a donné une
pleine mesure à ce moment en hausse à
cette histoire-là d'individualisation
d'appel à la responsabilisation d'appel
à l'auto entreprenariat de soi appel qui
a consolidé aussi on va voir comment la
fable de l'individu auto-construit car
j'ai plein de monde 1 là il n'y a pas de
solidarité que chacun se remette à ses
propres forces voir quels outils ça
représente 2 2 je suis presque on me
dira d'administration politique et
d'administration des consciences et il
ya deux j'utilise simultanément
simultanément qui sont apparus on a bien
compris à quoi je fais référence c'est
l'avènement simultanées alors là on est
là on est le résultat de tout cela
du téléphone portable et de l'internet
qui alors je tiens à dire tout de suite
tout de suite je j'en parle dans mon
bouquin de slash de l'argument tu
en quelques mots l'argumenter aussi
précisément
il y a eu qu'une aucune aucune utopie
liés aux réseaux et à internet c'est une
femme aucune utopie d'émancipation ça
c'est de l'utopie déchu tout ce qu'on
raconte depuis 20 ans est totalement
erronée c'est pas parce que quelques
geeks plus ou moins exaltée voire
éberlué en californie croyez qu'en
participant à des forums de discussion
ça allait pouvoir instaurer une
démocratie d'un nouveau genre dans le
prolongement de mac luhan et que ça
allait pouvoir organiser ce qu'aucune
internationale aucun projet politique
n'avait su mettre en place aucun sit in
et que depuis son canapé en tapant sur
le clavier nous allions avoir un nouvel
horizon politique fait d'émancipation et
collective ça c'était même pas une
poignée d'individus qui ont cru à cela
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais moi je sais
très bien pourquoi parce que les hackers
étaient dans cette mouvance les hackers
étaient totalement dans cette mouvance
là mais en réalité c'était totalement
l'illusion allez allez infondées qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire qu'en
communiquant entre nous ça allait
pouvoir faire émerger à monter
d'émancipation émancipation c'est quand
même l'autonomie de jugement c'est la
prise en charge de nos existences
individuelles et collectives c'est faire
valoir des existences plus vertueuse
suis très très bien de communiquer entre
nous mais de là à parler d'émancipation
dans ses passes pas qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il ya une industrie comme elle
a su le faire depuis de longues années
auparavant qui a donné des moyens les
outils qu'ils allaient pouvoir organiser
l'auto entreprenariat de soi là
l'organisation de plus en plus
individualisée et de nos existences et
kit qui est témoigné de la possibilité
enfin qu'il de décor à la possibilité de
quoi de deux principes majeurs la
mobilité téléphones portables la
mobilité qui est un des dogmes majeur de
n'est ce pas aujourd'hui on en revient
avec le co vie de la mobilité
circulation des flux continu des flux de
capitaux des personnes pardon
télétravail et du télétravailleur si tu
veux bien tout ça on y reviendra sur ce
qui s'est passé avec le télétravail les
technologies numériques et l'économie
avec le confinement le franchissement de
seuil j'ai écrit une tribune ya deux
semaines sur fiat qui est parue dans
libération il faut qu'on y revienne si
on a le temps
et
et l'idée que on allait pouvoir un peu
plus
acquérir des
ddd
dimension d'autonomie mais
principalement à l'intérieur de
dimension
individuelle il n'y a rien de politique
là j'ai rien contre sort mais individus
il n'y a rien de politique c'est pour ça
que je dis quand je dis individuelle et
tu viens d'en parler et sky high je
passe ici un ice assez ensemble un peu
haye
1998 je fais un peu le récit de cette
histoire
1998 mais 98 une des personnes qui a un
peu contribué parmi tant d'autres à
formater notre présent
steve jobs ce mais 98 à san francisco il
fait une de ses fameuses keynotes dont
tout le monde connaît le brio et peut
dire le très grand talent avec lequel il
a organisé ça il présente après être
revenu un an plus tard après de revenus
chez apple avec john zorn live le
formidable designer faut reconnaître le
talent de toutes ces personnes dans le
très grand talent le imac imac alors là
qui a fait vibrer déjà les gens sont
quand même voir ça c'est comme devant
les apple store de c'était je sais plus
comment s'appelle cette grande salle de
congrès à san francisco ça quand je dis
je suis allé voir de près tout ça
pendant deux ans allait analyser tout ça
de voir les motivations les ressorts de
ça je le redis moi je parle pas
épisodiquement notre dame qui brûlent
invité tout le temps sur les plateaux je
ne fais pas ça là je suis allé voir les
gens qui attendent san francisco la qui
note notamment plaint geeks et des
anciens hippies c'est ça dit des choses
sadi sur la fascination de ce monde
techno économique et
les foules étaient en transe après la
présentation de je n'ai rien contre ça
mais ça c'est pas d'émancipation c'est
l'idée d'être totalement excité par des
nouveaux outils qui sont mis entre nos
mains vu de vivre une existence plus
cool plus légère et qui en plus organise
la possibilité d'une plus grande
maîtrise individuelle sur nos outils à
dimension capitale notamment le l'apôtre
ans celui-ci delahaye maxis lite
souvient sky qui dès que je dis c'est
oublié c'était des couleurs acidulées
les pubs étaient très bien fait superbe
et puis pour pour apple de cours de ces
années là jusqu'à l'ipod
c'était des vert acidulé des bleus d
orange moi j'ai mis un bleu je suis très
content de l'avoir qui donnait le
sentiment d'avoir une vue presque
surplombant de qui offrait une maîtrise
sur la 800 ordinateurs collective puis
le ier puis après tout a été décliné le
mariage et le ipod et tout était
déclinée sur le sou je le sais ce que je
lui dise que analyser c'est que le high
est devenu ce que j'ai appelé le nouveau
taux poses de l'époque c'est à dire que
c'est allé avec de l'individualisation
ne sommes passés à la personnalisation
et à l'extrême personnalisation avec le
sentiment de retour de satisfaction sur
nous sur nos consciences de marco
l'industrie nous offrait des outils
permettant d'être de pouvoir d utiliser
de plus façon de plus en plus aisée
quand je des façons de plus en crise et
on voit bien de quoi je parle par
exemple
iphone le tactile des interfaces de plus
en plus charnel proches et
et cela cela s'est passé devant la dent
parce que je voulais j'ai eu un coup de
fatigue sur le aïe aïe peu
alors ça a donné le le sentiment de
pouvoir reprendre la main à l'intérieur
de devis ont trouvé on avait l'illusion
de pouvoir avoir toujours plus
d'autonomie mais ça c'est pas un projet
politique ça c'est pas d'émancipation je
dirais même plus loin aujourd'hui en
c'était déjà pour un grand nombre
d'entre nous
moi compris qu'on se retrouve qu'on
s'entende bien de ce que je dis moins
complet nous nous sommes laissés aller
au soda séduction c'est à dire de voir
là des moyens nous demande déjà ayant
valeur cathartique et nous donnant le
sentiment de un peu vivre
l'illusion d'autonomie de des moments de
confort d'accès à l'information des
choses qui oui nous procurer du plaisir
procuré l'illusion de pouvoir être et ça
a été un peu le cas un peu plus en
partie en partie stage jusqu'à avec des
limites parce qu'on vit en société un
peu plus maîtres de notre destin et
comme tous à être est allé très vite je
parle de hi hi macs en 98 j'ai parlé de
l'iphone qui est un point déterminant et
avant et après c'est comme la découverte
de l'amérique dans 492 en avant et après
c'est pareil à l'iphone un qui est plus
peut-être le dire pour probablement dire
pourquoi
mais qui a donné sentiments voilà c'est
dit c'est pas une sais pas c'est pas
c'est pas là ce n'est pas un projet
politique et ensuite cette industrie et
là on en revient à une des dimensions
majeures de notre époque
a donné le sentiment à donner des outils
aux personnes notamment entre autres et
puis plein d'autres à la suite
leur permettant
de s'exprimer de s'exprimer de faire
valoir des séquences de leur existence
et je pense très tôt à facebook en 2004
et à twitter en 2006 alors juste sur ses
deux soeurs se désolait deux événements
qui sont des événements à l'origine
technique économique un technico
économique qui vident sont devenus des
événements sociaux planétaire et qui
aujourd'hui sont des idées sont devenus
des événements politiques et
civilisationnel on a lu d'extension mais
ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que au moment même où des
personnes et on en a parlé au moment un
grand nombre de personnes vivaient des
effets de relégation de soi
d'invisibilité social
d'expérience d'humiliation d'expérience
d'une élite et d'inutilité aussi de soi
l'industrie du numérique
alors c'est pas prémédité non c'est pas
ça se passe comme ça donc on fait comme
ça presque on veut dire dans le même
moment parce que des interfaces le
permettait votre couple où il n'y a
aucun complot c'est un mouvement du
temps mais quand même il ya du flair et
du flair quand je dis du flair on
comprend que déjà ce que je veux dire en
creux c'est que nous on s'est laissé
prise au piège c'est un des coeurs de tu
me dis si j'étais inquiet
un des coeurs de mon attention on s'est
laissé prendre au piège parce que tu
comprends on souffre tellement on a
tellement l'impression de n'avoir aucune
valeur et coutumes peut être écoutée de
contient être représenté le pays de
représenter de continuellement entend
les mêmes sornettes et de voir que ça ne
se vérifie pas que ça ne ne prend pas
corps dans le dans l'ordre comme dans
l'ordre politique au moment même parce
qu'il faut voir les années je fais toute
une histoire m'a mise en perspective
historique de tous ces phénomènes dans
je suis désolé de dire encore dans mon
bouquin mais ce qu'il faut voir d'où on
vient il ya deux événements enfin 1 puis
l'autre il est plus diffus c'est 2008 la
crise des subprimes c'est de la finance
points majeurs point majeur
au moment même genre en terme
d'augmentation de la défiance ou de
l'augmentation de l'expression du peuple
à travers les nous
les deux exactement les deux c'est à
dire aux mômes
méfiance
des îles semapa désillusion parce que
c'est pas une désillusion confirmation
de la collusion entre politique et monde
de la finance on peut de la presse ou 6
mai mais une sorte de complaisant et
puis du législateur on a vu toutes les
failles juridiques il y avait mais aussi
des instances internationales
de l'om ses dauphins de tous de tout le
monde des failles ou où on a bien vu
qu'il y avait des rouages des pratiques
délictueuses pour un grand nombre
potentiellement
délétères on ne peut pas même dire
criminel parce que c'est comme la crise
de 29 il ya eu des suicides vies
fracassées tiens à vous parler des vies
fracassées des vies fracassées
tout cela après mitterrand et tous quoi
tout ce qu'on a dit l'un
et puis et puis des effets
en europe il ya eu des mécanismes un peu
d'interventions de l'état aux états unis
on sait très bien ce qu'il ya eu un
dd mais déménage à la rue des gens
ruinés
ok et puis dans les mêmes années
j'ai suivi et peut-être avons-nous tout
suivi parce que c'est extrêmement
important cela quand je dis on a été
fracassée et ce cas là je parle aussi à
la communauté interview
il ya eu le procès france télécom en
printemps dernier ou à l'hiver dernier
des salariés 2009 c'est à dire tu parle
de harcèlement le harcèlement
institutionnalisé
et pire encore confidentiel c'est à dire
qu'une induit une entreprise qui pour
partie c'est pas si elle était
entièrement privatisé à l'époque où il
faut vérifier j'ai un trou je pense que
les gens de la communauté peuvent
intervenir si orange s'était déjà orange
où c'était français comme en 2009 je ne
me souviens plus enfin il avait été
préparée déjà depuis quelques années
organisme de façon institutionnalisée
non publique le harcèlement des corps et
des esprits qui a concouru à des
troubles
musculo-squelettiques assis à des alors
avance à des
sentiments de de l'inutilité de soi les
témoignages qui a eu à france télécom je
les ai tous lus ce que j'ai presque on
lui dira ton prénom tellement là je suis
avec toi je vais pas te le dire mais je
les ai toutes ces il faut lire les
rapports de 2 c'est extrêmement
important le le rendu le rendu de
justice qui a eu d extrêmement important
c'est ainsi jurisprudence c'est
l'importance et criminal c'est du pénal
maintenant en 2009 c'était pas ça avait
été du pénal peut être que les
responsables n'auraient pas agi comme ça
trouble le sentiment d'unité de soi
expérience d'humiliation de relégation
de tout ce qu'on connaît dans le
management mais qui finalement était la
claque mais de mode de management est à
l'oeuvre dans le monde du travail depuis
une trentaine d'années avec cette
affaire de responsabilisation tu
comprends les personnes veulent peuvent
pas suivre les cadres c'est tellement
difficile on leur dit par soyez
inventifs donc pas c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé avec france télécom là
il va falloir to disrupt et c'était le
début de la disruption c'est à dire
c'était laurent alexandre avant l'heure
qui se réjouit de ce nouveau monde sans
se soucier d'eux on va m'a pas parlé de
laurent lexcellent tellement ce type ne
m'intéresse pas on l'a compris
déjà la disruption comme modèle
d'existence collectif sans se soucier de
toutes les conséquences donc en appeler
à la responsabilité l'inventivité sauf
que plein de personnes c'est que c'est
une façon de mettre au piège c'est à
dire de mettre chacun face à ses
responsabilités
et pour nombre de personnes à leur
incapacité si elles ne sont pas assez
formés
si elles ont dépassé un certain âge
aussi elles comprennent pas les flux
d'évolution de certaines choses dont
souffrent donc vous rendez vous compte
2008 ce prime 2009
mai 2009 contre quand je dis c'est
diffus un cd c'était déjà à l'oeuvre
depuis de longues années on a entendu
parler et puis ça n'a fait que se
confirmer on peut donner d'autres
exemples peut donner monsanto comme
exemple peut donner mon sang peut donner
servier toute cette affaire de collusion
entre monde politique et monde
économique et
jack dorsey twitter ait eu de carbone
lorsque ces autres shows 2004 donne des
instruments et je voudrais faire le
distinguo parce que lâche ça je vais
analyser de près et là je veux en venir
à nous mêmes nos propres responsabilités
facebook 2004 c'est pas du tout
l'expressivité de se voir le cade
c'était un son de ce maître nous avoir
ces projets des universités un
trombinoscope comme on dit un
chacun c'est s'exposer non c'était à
l'étrange sensation
je les ai vécus nous l'avons tous vécu
troublant réjouissante plaisante j'ai
même envie de dire au moment où nous
vivons des moments de votre dépression
collective
réconfortante de pouvoir s'exposer aux
yeux des eaux de raconter son quotidien
on a envie dire c'est pas très méchant
n'est ce pas sauf que une fois de plus
on a parlé de 2009
en 2009 qui est un événement technique
qui paraît anodin qui va en partie en
partie
imprimer notre notre quotidien notre
façon d'envisager les choses personne
nous comporter une autre façon de presse
que d'envisager le rapport aux autres
mais via les écrans
le pouce le 2009 c'est extraordinaire
c'est anodin petits pouces ou sade ou
pas vide 2 pouces adopte à dopamine et
assentiment de de quoi avec tout ce
qu'on a parlé notamment une encore faut
pas être moralisant faut voir comment ça
se passe c'est à dire entre entre des
choses vécues et des outils mis à
disposition et des systèmes et des
dispositifs et des interfaces
et des retours sur soi que ça induit et
le fait qu'on s'y prend on s'y prend
juste et apprécier la question de la
mesure la presse est la question la
mesure qui quoi qui apporte là où il ya
un sentiment
d'inutilité de soi de relégation l'as
dit un petit pouce dressé m'apportes des
salles de réconfort cotis ce n'est pas
rien c'est pas rien et le petit pouce
vers le bas il a disparu le 10 l'unc et
au début mais je pense qu'il n'existait
même pas il ya eu un moment de
propositions dislike il a jamais eu lieu
après il ya eu des plusieurs
déclinaisons qu'on connaît la de locker
le machin mais ça c'est extrêmement
important c'est pourquoi ça a été
important parce que
j'ai vu un effet de levier quand je dis
j'ai vu nous pouvons y voir un effet de
levier et qui induit
voilà
j'ai presque envie de dire le tragique
de notre condition c'est à dire entre
autres j'ai pas fini sur ça plutôt que
de nous atteler à
la tâche
plutôt que de faire valoir nos
possibilités d'action il ya eu on s'est
laissé aller à trouver de la
satisfaction bien là on peut c'est bien
normal appréciez la mesure comprenez
quand ça prend des mesures ou une des
sources principales de réconfort
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir l'illusion
d'être en contact avec les autres et
trouver sa dose de dopamine et de like
pour moi mais je maps très pas de seins
sky je ne peux y voir que le fait que
nous avons été malheureusement prise au
piège et que nous sommes pris dans un
dans des logiques de d'impuissance et
d'échec alors maintenant je vais dire
autre chose sur cette autopsie colonie
de logique
j'avais presque envie dire sauf toxiques
cela ne paraisse pas toxique
immédiatement et quand je dis ça je suis
pas moralisant fait moraliste ou songé
17e tient avec sa y avoir les moeurs du
temps ce que je fais depuis une
quinzaine d'années un parfois un peu je
vois des choses que des gens voient un
peu plus tard je pense que aujourd'hui
je peux le dire je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui vont réduire mais il a le melon
saddam mais c'est vrai tu disais
surveillance en 2009 n'est ce pas c'est
bien là tout le monde disait sadaoui les
paranoïaques un bon ok 2 mettra le
vitrail canada n'allait pas vraiment
tout le monde était dans l'émancipation
les réseaux
2009 flammarion les bouquins il existait
il a été imprimé en 2008 donc ça remonte
à bon
mais il ya eu après ces agrégés une
autre dimension que twitter a encouragé
ses l'expressivité s'est pas seulement
le contentement même si cela existe
quand je dis ça c'est pas substitutif ça
c'est un autre mouvement qui s'est
agrégée c'est celle de
donner nos opinions
extrait expressivité je n'ai rien contre
ça mais il faut voir comment ça se passe
d'abord comment ça se passe et où ça
nous mène alors comment ça se passe
d'abord ça se passe à l'intérieur
d'interface qui ont été conçus et
élaborés par l'industrie numérique
donc plus on exprime ses propres vignes
ont pu ça génère du chiffre génère des
dinos tas puis ça génère des data mais
moi pour moi là où j'en suis aujourd'hui
plus ça génère du chiffre plus ça génère
de la capacité à entretenir cela
et
ça a été nous l'avons dit 2004 facebook
2006 twitter ça a été
facebook c'est pas 2004 ainsi 2004 la
mise en ligne mais en réalité ces 2500 à
décoller à partir de 2008 2009 pareil
pour twitter 2006 2007 2008 on l'a dit
au moment même où il y avait cette
expérience de dépossession
capacités comme tu disais sky perdre
deux de confiance rupture d'adhésion à
au discours prononcé des terminales ça
on a été totalement dans la désillusion
est donc par effet mécanique
capacité à l'échelle planétaire
de d'exprimer aisément en quelques
instants
ceret sentiments ses colères ses ces
expériences mais pas n'importe quelque
pas de n'importe quelle façon puis à des
interfaces précisent ils et là je pense
nous l'avons compris peut-être à
l'interface de twitter à l'époque 144
caractère à l'image de
à l'instar de ce qui était pour les
téléphones portables cette époque-là
sankara que tu te souviens 140 à
l'époque c'était pas les iphone
et qui donc induit quoi l'interface est
à dire le régime de l'assertion tu
affirmes en 140 caractères là le poste
il est placé en amont et puis tu as les
commentateurs les commentaires en
dessous dans le clip d de l'idée de que
sa parole fait presque office de
d'apparition de dirt en premier avec
lesquels les gens viennent ensuite
commenté donc une sensation de
2,2 de l'importance de soi et 2 et 2 et
de surtout de
l'expression l'ex président moi
j'appelle pas ça les réseaux sociaux de
de l'expressivité
à satiété à nauseam l'âge du tout à
l'heure de ses opinions
on en arrive au point où ça produit quoi
pour voir où ça nous amène donc en jeu
pas moralisant ça amène a
le privilège de l'assertion au défaut au
détriment de l'argumentation donc du
dialogue qui appellent toujours du temps
pour être déployés
le privilège
de sa propre parole des rapports de plus
en plus clivée la brutalisation des
échanges
interpersonnels mais aussi
la consolidation de ses propres opinions
propres croyances au mépris au détriment
de ce que suppose la philanthrôpia de ce
que diana arendt dans la vie politique
c'est à dire la conversation la
conversation qui conduit à de l'amitié
l'amitié c'est pas on est tous copains
c'est la conversation on apprend des uns
des autres on avance et et et la porte
de l'autre m'enrichis lasser nous en
arrivons à un point par ces plateformes
où c'est le privilège continue de sa
propre parole mais c'est pas seulement
ça
je t'en prie le quand j'entends parler
des réseaux touche je suis et où on est
d'accord avec toi que
95% des gens l'utilisent pour brailler
brailler affirmé ou faire valoir leurs
souffrances mais à côté de ça il ya
encore des micro communautés qui
s'exprime avec un langage vernaculaire
en 144 caractère qui font résonner chez
l'autre grâce à de la musique et grâce à
la mémétique d'autres émotions qui
permette ans qui permet en fait de
d'échangé de partage et d'avoir la
bienveillance nous nous on essaye de
faire ça c'est très bien je te laisse
continuer mais je veux tu pourrais
continuer parce que c'est très important
ce que tu dis mais là c'est c'est pas
majoritaire s'est pas majoritaires
qu'est-ce qui est majoritaire alors là
je vais dire un point voyez ça c'est la
cg mis plusieurs mois penser à ça et est
à lire ça parce que c'est extrêmement
important
nous en arrivons au point où vu notre
situation
quand j'ai notre situation c'est
collectif
je parle de la fin d'un monde commun
pour l on peut le mettre ce point
d'interrogation qui est un drame
nous en arrivons au point
où notre condition politique parce que
cette situation-là appelle plus que
jamais à politiser notre existence
twitter parmi d'autres mais
principalement twitter a concouru au
mouvement de politisation croissante des
existences qui s'est passé au cours des
années 2010 n'est ce pas une
politisation je dirais plutôt
radicalisation a notamment nommé je
parle d'une façon générale dans la
société ces traits marquants de voir
qu'au cours des amis des années 2010
nous avons vécu un moment d'extrême peu
l'utilisation de nos existences avec des
effets de d'opposition de brutalisation
de forme de politisation en tous les cas
nous nommons les à minima une je pense
que nous nous sommes arrivés à un moment
de de conscience suicide des choses
qu'on notamment permis ces soucis ces
instruments c'est pour ça que les choses
sont complexes il faut voir la mesure
est ce là où nous amène à un moment je
dis ça arrivait à un moment de hargne
lucide nous avons compris que nous avons
compris que
pour un grand nombre d'entre nous un
ordre inique
avait été en oeuvre au détriment de
notre existence détriment de notre aide
notre intégrité au détriment de notre
dignité je pense aussi que nous avons il
faut comprendre ce que veut dire fake
news je vais revenir à un tweeter à la
politisation il faut comprendre ce qui a
été nommé fake news je pense qu'on n'a
rien compris sur l'histoire d'un fake
news c'est pas du tout comme disait
myriam revault d'allonnes dans un livre
alors là pour lequel très moralisant un
nouveau partage entre le vrai et le faux
la grande affaire et que ça met en
danger la démocratie la grande affaire
de dire ça mais tu es bon on est
installé tout ça c'est à nouveau partage
entre le je et le nous le jeu et de nous
le je et le nous
entre notre propre perception des choses
et les discours qui ne cesse de
véhiculer depuis une quarantaine
d'années quand pendant la guerre du
vietnam on n'arrêtait pas de nous dire
que enfin pas à nous mais en tout comme
on dit aux américains que
la guerre allait bientôt être terminé tu
suis les discours c'est bien tout halal
est de gagner un grand panneau de guerre
classique propagande de guerre oui mais
là le vietnam alès a été alors qu'ils
étaient les visions l'irak il ira
explorer non plus lire aggoun et c'était
plus court donc là ça a duré ça fait bon
ça fait de tous les dégâts de parts et
d'autres concerts du côté de la
population vietnamienne et des soldats
américains en général les plus d'éclat
c'est bon on va pas refaire cette
histoire mais la distorsion entre les
discours
la politique de l'union européenne qui
devait être plus sociales
ouais c'est quoi c'est pas des technos à
cebu c'est pas l'effet que muse c'est à
dire qu'on a vécu nous-mêmes
difficile il est beau moi je le
phénomène en tout cas objective des
faits qu il est il faut faut s'y atteler
de voir ce qu'il se jouer et les dérives
induites mais ça suffit pas de débarquer
défectueuse aussi instrumentalise il est
évident d'abord car quand il ya des
états qui font de l'ingérence qui
propagent xy ragots sur xy personnes
c'est une fête news pur et dur
maintenant les gens commencent à j'aime
pas dire les gens mais l'opinion
publique commence à être beaucoup plus
résilient de face à ce genre de
absolument donc il faut comprendre fait
que nous tu comprend de façon la plus
large que juste d'aller à ces terribles
les gens propagent des discours qui ne
correspondaient pas à la réalité une
fois que tu as dis ça t'a rien d'abord
tu as rien dit tu comprends rien aux
choses et puis ça ça ne fait
qu'amplifier notre nos angoisses et
notre désorientation pour ça que moi
j'essaye d'y voir plus clair c'est le
boulot que je fais 2009 pour moi
surveillance globale j'essaie d'y voir
plus clair l'enthousiaste des réseaux
été mais qu'est ce qui se joue à
l'époque bons de caisse alors fake news
mais anna par donc simone veil il a dit
desjardins alors dominant fêté en 2030
en 1930
le souci de la vérité je vais pas juger
la formule là mais je ne vais pas je
n'ai pas je retiens mal les formules
l'exil à l'exigence de vérité
est impérative en société elle est
impérative l'uni faisait pourtant nous
n'y faisons jamais mention diane arendt
qu'est ce que ça veut dire nous n'y
faisons jamais mention la veille ou d'un
simone veil tu veux je retrouve tout à
l'heure la la référente et pourtant
qu'est ce que ça vienne nous n'y faisons
jamais une mention ça veut dire que si
nous avons le sentiment l'impression ou
la vérification que des discours qui ne
vise qu'à entretenir
l'instauration d'un ordre qui n'a cessé
d'induire des injustices et qui a laissé
un grand nombre d'entre nous
cette exigence de vérité elle a été
bafouée
à nano nous faisons jamais mention à n'a
pas été suffisamment prendre encore plus
en compte et donc nous en payons les
conséquences nous en payons les
conséquences
donc ce qu'on a bien voulu aussi alors
je sais pas qui a voulu en tous les cas
il y a eu il y a eu mais ça c'est les
discours les 10 secondes scarlett tu te
souviens il ya deux ans presque jour
pour jour nous avons parlé des discours
forgé notamment le tout les think tanks
pour lui dit pour l'industrie du nuit
mais aujourd'hui ce que nous vivons et
que nous vivons avec le co vide ça je
comptais en parler plus tard nous vivons
la vérification que
depuis une quarantaine d'années nous
avons vécu une expertise à sion de nos
sociétés une sur expertise à sion de nos
sociétés c'est à dire que nous avons
laissé aux supposés sachant notamment
aux experts patentés par le monde
économique ou à une doxa helvétique ou
politiques pas tout ça c'est un must un
même ensemble inde il faut voir comment
se propage l'opinion la doxa
un air du temps là encore c'est pas
délibéré ça s'organise comme ça et qui
ont quoi qui ont valeur de vérité ce qui
compte et c'est un des enjeux mais là
c'est trop tôt pour moi d'en parler
maintenant probablement d'anti minutes
si tu es d'accord ce qui compte c'est le
terrain le policier tout à l'heure le
terrain ce qu'on vit qu'est ce qu'on vit
est ce que ça correspond à ce qu'on lui
dit il faut de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les hôpitaux alors que
ce qu'il aurait fallu pour les hôpitaux
psy et du soin c'est du personnel c'est
finance les campagnes de ton on voit là
et c'est pas des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle dont déjà il ya deux ans
j'avais dit qu'il était inutile et que
ce qui peut laisser le soin il ya deux
ans bon ça c'est un drame c'est un drame
tous ces discours fort je donc ce que
nous avons ce que nous vivons
avec ce que j'aille nomme mois les
plateformes de l'expressivité
et là encore il s'agit pas d'être
moralisant mais qui ont accompagné
favoriser
des formes de politisation de la société
à l'échelle planétaire le chien globale
au cours des années 2010 mais comment
elles se sont passées ces forme de
politisation qui certes ont pris la
forme de conscience collective de plus
en plus tu presque dire lucide faut pas
que ça prenne des mesures quasi parano
qui tend vers la paranoïa mais lucide
c'est quoi on l'a dit c'est l'échec des
politiques néolibérales de politique
économique de plus en plus débridée dont
dont nous en avons tous payé les frais
mais ça s'est manifesté cette
politisation par quoi principalement ela
jeu tout chaud au coeur de ma conviction
de ce sur quoi je veux alerter ce soir
et avec mon livre et de ce sur quoi je
veux signaler un point qui nous
regardent tous et qui peut nous emmener
dans des voies à minima extrêmement
périlleuse alors c'est
quoi cette cette affaire de politisation
certes il ya eu une repolitisation des
sociétés quand lipovetsky pour un livre
des années je crois que ça date de 83 44
son bouquin l'ère du vide c'est qu'à
plus de politisation houdou harker
canaille moeurs ou adorno qui disait la
société de consommation dont je parlais
tout à l'heure ça concourt à une
dépolitisation une rechute prise en
charge des individus et la société de
leur propre destin il avait raison il ya
eu dépolitiser choix purement il ya une
politisation un qui est apparue versa
poids et moules à 10,1 ce point ce
moment à l'échelle globale etc ont rendu
possibles les usages des technologies
numériques un très important comme quand
il change les choses sont éminemment
complexe qui ont rendu la veine possible
l'avènement
globale à l'échelle globale d'une
conscience et qui ensuite a pris la
forme d'une cotisation c'est à dire d'un
refus de tout d'un rejet qui pouvait
prendre des formes multiples inde de
position pour aller très vite de gauche
de droite ou absolument à l'écart du
tout parti politique ce qui est ce qui
est appelé à être de plus en plus le cas
on va probablement y revenir avec ce
phénomène la gouvernabilité permanente
et s'apprend quelle forme ça prend la
forme
il faut revenir à aristote et à 1 à
rennes que j'ai beaucoup cité la
dernière fois mais on comprit qu'elle
nourrit mon pour large partie mon
travail pas seulement
ça mais en échec
parce que c'est très bien d'exprimer ses
sentiments et ses rancoeurs et ses
opinions et ses expériences et ses états
d'âme et ses expériences d'humiliation
quotidienne et son trop plein de
d'insatisfaction dont on peut dire a
priori a priori pour la plupart que les
souffrances son gma pas dire légitime
mais ça ne veut rien dire des
souffrances légitime qu'ils appellent de
la tension qui appelle à s'exprimer
mais il y à un moment et là c'est un
point majeur de notre moment historique
et notamment après les gilet jaune 2018
dont nous allons reparler il y à un
moment dans toute société et dans tout
cours collectifs des choses est dans le
moment politique de nos existences où
les paroles il faut qu'une traduction en
actes une traduction en actes
individuels mais surtout collectivement
parce que le positif c'est pas
l'individu c'est pas une dimension
individuelle de m'exciter avec mon imac
qui font fait lever les foules lors la
quine de 98 ans mais 99 steve jobbs
traduire en acte politiquement c'est
collectivement c'est collectivement donc
déjà l'expression via les écrans c'est
c'est une expression qui témoignent déjà
qui a lieu via des interférences qui se
passe vers les écrans et derrière
derrière c'est court mais c'est pas ça
mon problème c'est pas ça le point que
je souligne tu reviens
à aristote repris par qu'est ce qui dit
aristote dans la grèce qu'à vous
réfléchi n'est ce pas à la démocratie au
moment où ou actuellement nous
réfléchissons beaucoup à la démocratie
de nouvelles conditions des nouvelles
possibilités de faire valoir des
procédures démocratiques renouvelables à
la lumière de tout ce que nous avons
vécu de tous les dégâts et de toutes les
dérives de nos schémas supposé
démocratique que nous avons vécu et de
nous avons vu toutes les limites
aristote dit la condition politique et
que hannah rennes reprend ses deux ce
sont deux dimensions indissociables il
faut bien entendre ce que je vois quand
j'ai lu ça il sait y ait eu un avant et
un après quand j'ai compris ça c'est ce
que et que théorise à nouveaux frais
hannah arendt dans la condition de
l'homme moderne je crois la citation
il dit c'est le bios politicos c'est à
dire c'est la condition politique qu'est
ce que c'est la condition politique ce
sont exclusivement
prioritairement réalité exclusivement
c'est que de choses pas trente six mille
choses c'est deux choses
c'est une tension indissociable
entre l'action
et la parole entre la praxis en dix ans
grecs et l'alexis la parole ce que
principe notions extrêmement importantes
que théorise à nouveaux frais à n'arrête
mais
reprécise hanna reitsch pas si elle le
dit ou moi j'ai compris comme ça je me
souviens plus voir le texte il ya une
primauté chronologique ya une primauté à
l'action c'est là qu'est ce que ça veut
dire praxis et laxiste c'est à dire
qu'on est dans l'action on est sur le
terrain de l'action la politique c'est
ensemble on décide c'est pour ça que
faut revenir aux assemblées citoyennes
revenir à
l'action sur le terrain on décide
ensemble tant compte peu à toutes les
échelles pas seulement l'air d'une
dimension pyramidale qui est un des
enjeux majeurs qui remise en question
aujourd'hui sur le sur le terrain de nos
vies quotidiennes de nos vie collective
de nos vie commune le monde commun un
monde commun on engage des actions et
puis après ça engage ça ça produit quoi
mais du discours caisse c'est le
discours c'est l'évaluation en commun
dans la contradiction dans la pluralité
dans le respect dans le respect sky une
fois puis j'allais dire ton ton prénom
totalement jeu le respect dans l'ain
philanthrôpia l'amitié et est aussi dans
le conflit il ya du conflit en société
je remets au grec llagonne llagonne
c'est le construit on se fripe on se
frite en vue de quoi
d'aboutir à des accords qui à nouveau
engagent des actions
et qui a à nouveau
prolongée par une évaluation collective
et c'est là que le discours entre en
oeuvre c'est c'est l'intelligence terre
le discours c'est notre intelligence
humains human intelligence on se met en
intelligence tu comprends intelligente
et on se met en position à dire de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé je dire ça
c'est bien ça on n'est pas d'accord ça
peut faire autrement c'est dans
l'évolution du temps aussi des choses
sont toujours à construire toujours sur
le chantier or que vivons nous
aujourd'hui c'est un des drames de notre
temps nous vivons une asymétrie mon pu
dire une dissymétrie comme jamais mais
comme jamais dans l'histoire entre le
discours et l'action entre des flots
discours qui ne cesse des véhicules qui
sont encouragés par les dix réseaux
sociaux mais aussi par les chaînes
d'information continue mais aussi par la
production la circulation ininterrompue
d'information qui crée quoi qui crée le
sentiment que chacun existe par
l'énonciation de sa propre parole qui a
le don à 15 pour le quasi intégralité de
quoi
de ne strictement rien produire sinon de
nous renvoyer à notre propre croyance
sinon de nous renvoyer à notre propre
constat constamment constat constamment
réitéré de notre impuissance et
l'amplification et l'aggravation
continue elle de cet état des choses que
j'ai évoqués en lit mineur on peut en
préambule de brutalisation continue de
désorientation collective et de
sentiment que quelque chose
voilà une sorte de situation dont on ne
saisit plus comment nous allons pouvoir
organiser collectivement en conscience
les choses et donc cela cela crée
quantité déjà de dérive moi je sais pas
combien de temps on a ou tu veux qu'on
aille maintenant sky mais il ya des
choses que j'ai encore à dire tout cela
sur cet échec là combien de temps nous
avons encore
fait pas combien noble que je continue
comme si situe mon mich devient bon
donc il y à ce que je nomme moi parce
que je nomme
des impasses d'ailleurs nous vivons le
drame c'est que nous vivons un double
échec terre de l'échec des politiques
néolibérales au lieu de travail et son
peuple on dira c'est aussi comme ça
travailler ont retroussé les manches on
dit ou non de bretagne ou de nous
atteler sur le terrain concret de nos
vies quotidiennes on vient d'un autre et
chaque os et pas convient parce que
c'est à dire on vit on se laisse aller à
un autre échec certes landes là j'en
appelle à la responsabilisation la
responsabilité de nous tous nous raconte
line tous c'est à dire jusqu'à quand la
question que je pose ce soir 6 octobre
jusqu'où et jusqu'à quand allons nous
aller dans cette on peut le dire dans
cet effet de psychiatrisation de la
société jusqu'où jusqu'à quand jusqu'à
et à quel moment en société
mais c'est le plus difficile je pense
que c'est plus difficile
allons-nous nous donner les moyens de
traduire nos ressentiments pour la
plupart légitime fondée
déterminer ce truc façonné depuis très
longtemps j'ai dit jusque par delà les
générations
notre open et presque 2
et presque 2 2 n
comment allons-nous
c'est le plus dur nous démener les
moyens de
les traduire en actes je sais bien que
là c'est des paroles que je dis mais il
faut que maintenant de nous mettions à
la tâche alors mettions à la tâche j'ai
des choses à dire sur ce lascar est en
marche ben non justement
justement j'ai déjà dit ça a quelque
chose sur ça la france forme à la
françois marche
en 2017 moi j'ai dit à un moment dans
l'émission de télévision d'une personne
que vous aviez reçu la natacha polony
sur paris première l'idée n'est pas de
nous mettre en marche pas nous mettre en
action ce petit om chose mais je viens
sur l'histoire de mémoire là la passion
de la haine prend son temps pour
s'enraciner profondément et penser à
l'adversaire la passion de la haine
prend son temps pour s'enraciner
profondément et penser à l'adversaire je
suis dit tu vas me dire qui c'est je
veux dire qu'il ya écrit ça
ça prend son temps c'est le temps là
nous vivons ça n ressentiment saturation
nous vivons le moment d'une extrême
saturation à cause de quantité de choses
de nombreuses choses que nous avons
décliné narré jusqu'à maintenant cette
extrême saturation c'est notre lot c'est
notre
expérience et nos existences et notre
conscience c'est notre
état de
on n'en peut plus
j'ai presque envie de dire c'est sont
les dernières années 2017 2018 pour moi
il ya deux événements décisifs qui se
sont passées ces dernières années depuis
que nous sommes vus
c'est entre autres va y en a il y en a
trois à mon sens les deux premiers qui
sont qu'un c'est le gilet jaune et plaza
italia
à santiago du chili qui soulignait que
quelque chose de mondial c'était une
saturation plaza italia c'est la
saturation des logiques de chicago boys
depuis 73
en gros c'est là en 2010 a eu le temps
des places
vous parlez on parle et on faisait les
récits à la peine et en même temps rêver
à d'autres modalités d'existence plus
souhaitable c'est terminé le temps des
places maintenant c'est le temps des
ronds-points quelconque envie la
situation les affects s'exprime par les
insectes est conscient s'exprime et
disent trop c'est trop et parfois trop
c'est trop jusqu'à des moments de
violence dont il faudrait trouver un
autre mot à dire de traduction par les
impacts d'une de saturation légitime
après le plus grand dans le plus grand
enjeu politique le plus grand enjeu
politique qui nous regardent tous c'est
de traduire en actes collectivement ces
effets de saturation c'est cela enfin
c'est ça qui nous qui nous a conquis on
est comme moi alors je vais en parler à
vous dire alors je veux en parler parce
que je préparais vois tu je vais en
parler sky parce que je prépare là c'est
la phase de diagnostic où je parle
d'action aussi à la fin et je prépare un
livre sur sa voile ce sera un autre
moment et d'ici là entre les deux je
parlerai peindre je ne parlerai pas
parce que là tout est dit pour moi
jusqu'à maintenant quand je disais quand
je disais tu ces trois événements dont
il ya sàrl le tente ce que je nomme le
temps des ronds-points et que je nomme
le temps de l'ingouvernabilité
permanente situe à quelques minutes
faudra qu'on parle de ça qui me semble
être un point un principe décisive de
notre temps qui n'est pas du tout les
populismes contrairement à ce que disent
tant de sociologues et des politologues
qui ont à mon sens procède par courtes
et vu
le deuxième événement c'est
ce que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
extrêmement rapidement c'est l'évolution
qui seront rapidement de nous montrer
dit il s'est passé quelque chose cette
conscience les voilà et puis évidemment
le troisième c'est la crise que nous
vivons mais surtout la conscience de
tout les peler et de toutes nos dérives
et du fait que c'est pas seulement nos
vies voilà nos vies individuelles avons
souffert dans le travail c'est comment
déglingué le service public déglingué
des glaives déglingué les structures
déglingué les institutions déglingué des
hôpitaux déglingué l'hôtel hôtel
déglingué l'école déglingué toutes les
institutions dont nous avons besoin les
avons besoin d'institutions et
mégalomanie oui oui enfin en tous les
cas
soumission à un ordre parce qu'il faut
pour voir pourquoi l'hôpital public a
été tellement à la traîne tu vois
pourquoi parce que numérisation de
l'hôpital public à outrance cette doxa
avec les personnels qui se parlaient
plus que mais voilà dualisation de tous
l'idée que par par des statistiques par
des logiques de performance au chiffre
va bref toute une série de choses
allaient pouvoir espère toujours la même
histoire responsabilité des personnels
hospitaliers qui disent écoutez vos
d'auxerre vont vos paroles entre quatre
propositions n'ont aucune valeur elles
sont totalement hors sol et écouter ne
souffrent pas écoutés nous a pas écoutés
sarkozy réduction du personnel
hospitalier bref et puis on a vu ce que
co lead a révélé il faut quand même que
je cite cette phrase avant de venir à
juste de 10,2 qui aliène de qui elle
vient
alors ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est quand
mais c'est par cette phrase que
c'est par cette phrase que je vous les
citez sky en deux mots avant de devenir
à notre affaire de publicité une phrase
plutôt qu'une autre mais c'est ça le
sont dans le même esprit la tempête a
son origine dans le passé
n'est ce pas dans des régions lointaines
la bruine la brume froide et l'air chaud
on l'entend longtemps lutté avant que la
grande rupture des équilibres tirait la
tempête ne se forme ce magnifique ce
magnifique
pierre kropotkine creux kropotkine que
nous connaissons tous la révolution qui
vainquit viens moi je les lui d'un
régicide jc par vous même dans la tarn
donc voilà donc la tempête voilà ça
savez c'est ce moment de saturation
donc de l'avons dit
le défi qui nous incombe ces deux de
contredire de nous opposer à ces 10 et
mitry cette asymétrie entre logos
et praxis d'entre
entre praxis et lexis
et
est plutôt que d'en vouloir
continuellement à
l'ordre des choses à juste titre à son
voisin à son à son actif je trouve un
autre mot à son interlocuteur ou à son
follower je ne sais qui
comment allons nous donner les moyens
maintenant
plutôt que de faire valoir la
prééminence de soi sur instagram c'est
quand même extraordinaire c'est pas de
l'artiste et nous vivons pas du tout une
période de narcissisme une période où
alors que nous sommes de plus en plus
des possédés nous utilisons des
instruments nous donne en soi le
sentiment de l'importance de nous mêmes
soit le sentiment de pouvoir nous mêmes
marchandises et notre vie c'est à dire
d'organiser un libéralisme de nous-mêmes
ce sens alors pas du tout le libérer
alors là dans ce cas là à 7 à cette
enseigne bravo l'industrie du numérique
dans la bras voilà c'est extraordinaire
alors que l'industrie numérique essaye
attentes et s'est efforcé depuis une
dizaine d'années de marchandises et tous
les pans de notre existence à nous a
offert notamment via instagram et parmi
d'autres s'interface l'occasion de
monétiser la visibilité publique de nos
comportements c'est extraordinaire alors
là si on n'a pas été prise au piège si
c'est pas l'auto en propre l'auto en
prêtre entrepreneuriale de nous mêmes
sous le soleil californien est
apparemment heureux et qui produit des
nouveaux jeux de pouvoir il faut pas
s'en prendre qu'aux institutions qui
produit des nouveaux jeux de pouvoir
d'individus sur un individu si
aujourd'hui un des grands enjeux
d'organisation de sa vie personnelle
c'est de produire un ascendant
symbolique sur les autres en vue de
créer des nouveaux repères de
comportement et dégénéré la visibilité
de sa vie comme cash machine on a beau
dénoncer le libéralisme du matin au soir
comme des gens as tu remarqué sky je
vais revenir à nos actions à l'action
politique mais moi quand à chaque fois
que je vois je suis pris par collage de
mes propres colère aussi un sont celles
ci mais elles sont aussi parfois d'un
autre ordre quand je vois des gens sky
et ça tout le monde
appelle à la communauté à toute la
communauté stinger je pense tout le
monde a vu ça quand je vois des gens
notamment sur la plateforme facebook et
notamment à la veille des élections
présidentielles de par le monde je pense
qu'en 2022 envoya voir notre lot mais on
y est déjà car il ya une ville une
vulgate anticapitaliste aujourd'hui qui
est devenu général moi j'ai rien contre
elle c'est les modalités parce qu'on
sait très bien que gentil techno libéral
ça + 2
cette bouquin sur sa péniche
j'ai fait a écrit une tribune j'ai pas
eu le temps sur amis c'est bon il y en a
d'autres qui l'ont faire on va plus ou
moins bien
mais qu'en plus ou moins bien mais quand
cette vulgate la cette passion
néolibérale elle s'exprime du matin au
soir
sur facebook et twitter des plateformes
silicone yann qui font le lit de
situations cours et qui génère du
chiffre d'affaires mesdames et messieurs
je vous parle en amis les amis ses
interviews est-ce que vous n'y voyez pas
là une contradiction un dévoiement c'est
à dire de gueuler contre le monde
néolibéral du matin soit sur les plates
formes
vraiment est-ce que vous n'y voyez pas
une contradiction j'ai presque envie
dire morale pas seulement
comportementale moral et qui en plus
fait le lit de ceux techno libéralisme
moi je vois je vois d'aidé et et
notamment jeu là peut-être je vais pas
me faire des amis
moi j'en ai assez d'une chose que je
vois c'est pas méchant mais ça imprime
les comportements on va parler de
l'action à ce cas ici tu es d'accord
saint-prime les comportements le dit
partager le partage par les discours ça
vient du cher en anglais 1 le partage
c'est une belle notion humaine comme de
partager les choses avec autrui de
partager un repas de partager un point
de vue comment nous sommes fait avoir
avec ce charter l'économie du cher qui
était du cher comme ma grand mère
et je sais pas alors c'est pas du cher
c'était une illusion du char alors
maintenant
cliquer sur un article il suppose et le
partage est ce pas du tout du partage
méfions-nous des termes il vient de la
langue anglaise on avait parlé sur avait
à propos de rouelles la dernière fois
sky sur lors de mon dernier passage
c'est pas un partage sais pas si j'ai
absolument pas de partages diffuser
l'information qu'est ce que ça donne un
sentiment de satisfaction de ses propres
positions dans le sens de nos positions
au contraire et on partage martigues
nations partagent continuellement avec
parfois une petite formule
plus ou moins satisfaite de soi ou plus
ou moins dénonciatrice
c'est ça la politisation existence c'est
ça en plus sur des plateformes c'est
quoi ces plateformes pas du service
public s'est pas créée par des hackers
puisque vous venez de ce monde la grippe
a il faut quand même être conscient de
faire un arrêt sur image comme vite à
ton ami jeunes et d'hermann qui est
venue quelques années c'est bonjour on
lui passe le bonjour si tu veux tu
laissé au hasard faisons un arrêt sur
l'image quelques instants pour rendre
nous rendons nous compte de deux
dévoiement
de nous diffuser deux plateformes de
l'expressivité en général de la
dénonciation de ce monde néolibéral
techno libéral en se servant de ses
plateformes enfin quand même et en plus
les journées font que 24 heures nous
avons l'énergie que nous avons et en
plus de dépenser de l'énergie du matin
au soir ah parce que c'est de l'énergie
quand c'est quand il ya eu voit des gens
faire cinquante mille enfin je sais pas
trois quatre postes les travailler les
pesées c'est des choses qu'on ne fait
pas d'autres activités
quand je dis activités on va arrêter
ailleurs m le terme d'activité de côté
10 secondes l'action comment traduire
politiquement cet état c'était un
certainement pas
dans le rejet de l'autre dans le rejet
de deux personnes supposées être
privilégiée dans cet ordre comme un mois
j'ai été très frappée il faut faire
quand il faut faire des actions locales
alors je t'écoute non mais c'est moi je
suis pas là pour faire des propositions
je pose une question est ce qu'il faut
faire des actions locales est-ce qu'il
faut se recentrer sur des petits groupes
à ce qu'il faut recréer du lien qui si
vous faire
je peux vous faire part d'une petite
réflexion
avant de répondre à ça par rapport aussi
à des échecs
le meurtre de george floyd en mai
scandale ait enfin bon le
pps même bon paix à son âme
et c'est durant de longues minutes
laissez-moi respirer c'est tellement let
me in the reef ont pu en tant que ça
tellement niveau il
faut l'entendre sa parole alors ne
regardez que son état mais ces lettres
me bouffe c'est la première fois je me
dis ça tient peut-être que cela 2010 vif
c'est quelque chose qui nous regardent
tous une âme l'eau j'en ai presque la
chair de poule dire sa tête libre il est
à ce prix
bon il ya eu car il ya eu quantité
d'injustice l'heure est à la réparation
aux réparations
pourquoi je dis ça pour quoi je parle
avant l'action parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup tu comprends quand tu sors d'un
livre était plein de réflexions t'es
plein de
d'analystes et plein de choses que tu as
laissé de côté parce que tu peux pas
tout mettre dans un bouquin 300 talent
mettez plaint aussi de moments tu te dis
des choses et voilà tu vois là ça ça
parle
le racisme aux états unis nous
connaissons tous dans toutes les
sociétés des pays du nord soucy une en
france aussi et usage de la force
parfois
souvent excessif delà des forces de
l'ordre nous avons besoin de la police
c'est pas nous avons besoin
d'institutions nous avons besoin d'après
et après c'est toutes les dérives c'est
les formations le gars que j'ai
rencontré tu sais ce qu'il m'a dit il
mais dit le drame de la police
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont totalement
inculte voudrait faire de la culture jeu
c'est génial de me dire ça mais c'est un
grand monsieur le gars a visité une
école de police tu vas comprendre non
mais le gars c'est un grand monsieur
c'est à dire que ils me disent allez
c'est un sociologue n'est pas que flic
le mec il dit vous n'imaginez pas
monsieur quand ils arrivent en formation
ils ne connaissent rien ne connaissent
rien ils sont totalement dans des
logiques on va faire l'ordre et puis
savent pas les voiliers les souffrances
dans paris les comprennent même pas
c'est l'idée faut suivre les ordres et
puis boum mais on peut comprendre aussi
de
peu moins ça maintenant c'est plus la
stabilité du boulou pour prendre son
petit emprunt dans sa petite maison
messac et comment peut on dans cette
femme dont comment on peut condamner ça
mais je reviens
ce qui s'est passé à ce drame là car il
y a il ya des plaies il ya les
souffrances qu'ont vécu quantité de
communautés dans le monde entier aux
états unis et notamment et notamment les
populations noires en france aux états
unis partout mais aussi de populations
immigrées il ya des choses à réparer il
y en a plein il y en a plein alors moi
j'ai été très marqué
la destruction des statuts par exemple
moi j'ai été très marqué par ça
j'ai envie de dire je vais revenir à
l'action mais on parle de beaucoup de
choses ce soit je pensais pas être aussi
en forme et je suis avec vous et je vois
pas souvent je vois pas souvent et là
vraiment c'est le voilà c'est le soir
après des longs mois de travail une
année qui m'a lessivée travail et la vie
dit ça serait ce soir là ensemble et je
suis très heureux d'être avec vous ce
soir
plein trop-plein d'affect on peut le
comprendre on n'en peut plus de ces
injustices qui datent pas de l'unss
ce que j'ai lu de kropotkine salah pas
si c'est ça prend ça se cristallise et
puis un moment c'est trop destruction
des statuts c'était voilà c'est les
corps qui s'expriment les consciences
qui s'exprime ça suffit on n'en peut
plus mais moi je me suis dit en
regardant sa gelée 10 et on comprend
évidemment non pas complet comment ne
pas compatir comment ne pas adhérer
comme on n'est pas mais ce que ce serait
pas mieux par exemple action politique
tient demain des plaques
de faire le récit de ce qui s'est passé
on a même mine pour ce monsieur pour
cette dame n'y a pas beaucoup de dames
pour ce personnage une statue érigée en
ériger en à propos de tels personnages
qui habitude était à l'année at-elle
année qui a peut-être fait de l'action
telles actions vertueuses ce qui
justifie qu'une ceinture mais dont on a
compris avec le temps travail
d'historien et travail de quantité de
choses qu'il avait fêté les exactions
voire tel crime du rite et
ça me fait penser et ça apaise ça fait
travailler les consciences a fait
travailler des historiens ça fait
travailler la puissance publique de dire
on va s'investir dans cela ça c'est un
point extrêmement important de l'état
deux attaques tel état tu fais référence
au fait qu'on a déboulonné des statuts
match du mans absolument et moi je pense
par exemple à déboulonner les bonnes
ouais mais si tu veux
les gestes on les comprend on peut dire
ce qu a pas d'autre stratégie que de
casser que de détruire car là c'est la
question destruction c'est à réparer
tout ça est à réparer la mémoire est à
réparer la même trop tard alors c'est
pas trop alors tu dis est ce que c'est
trop tard vous en passez pas trop tard
que je te coupe parce que bon c'est pas
trop ça on a une hyper accélération de
la mondialisation on a un bombardement
nos cerveaux avec des hyperstimulation à
longueur de journée et oui qui la
plupart du temps sont faits soit pour
nous je fais un générer du trafic ou des
dates à vous faire sortir ma carte bleue
et on se retrouve avec une classe
politique qui est en short dès qu'il ya
une situation de crise on
voit comme la mer se retire et on voit
leurs shorts et des fois il y en a mais
il y en a qu'on pas de shorts et et
ensuite ils se rattrapent aux branches
en ayant une communication qui est dit
de brasser du vent scut et de l'air
chaud ou même travestir la pensée la
langue française et enfin sont à une
population qui a depuis les 40 dernières
années lui une trépanation dans sa
capacité à se saisir absolument donc
c'était de bras oui mais c'est pas trop
tard alors tu poses la question où tu la
firme dont je pose la question tu poses
la clé alors en termes d'action
relativement et ça prend avec humour et
çà
et là c'est du concret mais je vais
parler d'action encore je vais me dire
plus concrètes non plus concrètes sur le
terrain de nos vies que dit il ya là
collectivement plus concret c'est à nous
en société nous en terme en tant que
citoyens nous en tant que professeurs
dans les écoles nous en tant
qu'historien nous en tant que société
est aussi que communauté d'appartenance
on nous sommes nous avons des
communautés apparemment et nous sommes
aussi tous dans la république française
et dans un supposé communauté de destin
c'est à nous de faire en sorte que
notamment dans l'éducation
la mémoire soient mieux respectés les
murs nous l'avons payé cela ils
s'épanouissent foule thinking
l'éducation s'est passé pas des
incantations sais pas l'éducation le
système éducatif français ils sont en
train de se faire ravage et on se tape
une crise sanitaire qui supprime les
interactions il faut qu'on en parle mais
là il faut que j'aille au bout de sa
résidence c'est à dire c'est à nous et à
travailler moi j'ai découvert que mes
textes et est maintenant dans les
programmes de philosophie de terminale
hatier et nathan voulait terminale
technologique j'étais très content
serait pas été le cas en 2015
2020 c'est intéressant l'évolution des
mentalités je suis dans les programmes
scolaires ne comptait pas en parler je
veux ça flatte l'ego je sais pas que ça
flatte l'ego franchement ça va pas fait
beaucoup d'effet on dort this may 10 à
10 jours doivent être super content
franchement ça m'a rien fait seulement
ça a été un signe des temps là que mes
textes hypercritique souad en classe de
terminale notamment en termes
technologiques
produira peut-être qu'un effet mais
quand même des générations de profit des
flots de professeurs et d'élèves où on
voit des textes critiques notamment sur
l'intelligence artificielle ia pas
laurent alexandre dans l'aider dans les
programmes de terminale alors là la
coche l'aller justice excusez moi là
j'en ai profité non laurent alexandre tu
n'y es pas la droite pour le terminer et
à juste titre mais est-ce que je
reparlerai plus de ce monsieur est ce
que philippe allain nuageux surtout
qu'on voulait me faire faire un débat
ici j'ai refusé tout le monde a compris
pourquoi ça ne sert à rien d'abord de me
répéter de débattre avec ce genre de
personnage je voulais débattre avec
viviani là il a décliné mais maintenant
lui est devenu un quasi amish deux ans
plus tard il a parlé de sobriété mais au
numérique en répondra macron c'est très
intéressant l'évolution des mentalités
mais il faut que je revienne à mon
affaire là je suis très en forme ce soir
donc dès que je partage un truc dont je
revienne à chaque fois au point initial
de 2 chaque mot de chaque séquence
[Musique]
travaillons en société là où nous le
pouvons et au et auprès des politiques
menées auprès de l'inspection académique
mais auprès d'eux des maires des grandes
villes et notamment idéal go pour toutes
les statues qui a à paris et pour les
programmes scolaires à ce que les
mémoires soient mieux respectés vous
rendez compte moi j'en parle dans mon
livre je vous dis que j'ai pesé les mots
parce que c'est hyper délicat c'est
hyper sensible ce que je vais dire lance
hypersensible qu'on en arrive à ce que
des gamins de 12 13 ans je sais pas quel
âge 12 13 ans
c'est terrible ce que je vais dire on le
connaît tous ce que je vais dire on
arrive à rejeter un enseignement sur la
shoah est un crime contre l'humanité
c'est pas seulement les suivre c'est
nous tous un drame de l'humanité
d'amener des femmes des enfants des
hommes par des camps de la mort au seul
nom de leur appartenance ethnique c'est
un crime contre l'humanité mais de
rejeter la possibilité même d'avoir à
faire à cet enseignement de dire on n'en
veut pas
parce que d'autres plaies
qui ont souffrir plein d'autres
à d'autres moments et à d'autres ces
moments d'histoire d'autres jeux
d'autres l'esclavagé la colonisation
ne sont pas suffisamment enseigner ça
nous arrive à quoi nous donc les l'est
où les parents des étudiants on n'en
veut pas de votre truc parce que ça ne
fait qu entretenir ce mode là un ordre
supposé inique mais on en arrive à
l'échec du refus de rejet et de dire
l'enseignement de la shoah y en a marre
tu te rends compte que l'échec au lieu
de dire oui nous voulons apprendre des
exactions horrible qui se sont déroulés
nous voulons autant à prendre avec des
témoignages afin des témoignages en tout
cas pour la colonisation c'est possible
la colonisation c'est le pour la
cotisation pour l'esclave un jeu bon
même s'il ya des nouvelles formes
d'esclavagé nous voulons apprendre que
ce soit documenté et qui est une part
dans les programmes et qui soit dit aux
élèves
avec le temps il s'est passé des choses
il ya les programmes sont refaits sonné
et dans les villes les plaques on met
des plaques ont détruit pas ça sert à
quoi d'être les plaques de détruire les
boulonnaises pétille ça ne sert à rien
bouger et moi je sais je sais ça peut
être un acte fort considéré comme un
acte fort pendant un moment gagné un
moment pour tout comme dit la bible
c'est pas religieux mais il ya un moment
pour tous c'est vachement beau ce truc
de la pluie dans quel monde appelait son
passé c'est qu'on est condamné à le
revivre mais oui mais il ya un moment
pour tous à un moment pour le pour
l'expression des affects de la ville il
ya un moment où on a commencé à parler
de deux de la traduction de la
traduction
politique je sais que je voulais dire
une autre chose
traduction politique si l un des claques
et programmes scolaires mais il y avait
un truc vachement important mais la
finale technologique non non c'était pas
ça petite parenthèse super important à
propos du rejet de allaoui par exemple
donc pour les programmes
est-ce qu'on société nous tous en
société monde comme un dis-je est ce que
ce serait pas un grand projet politique
un grand projet éducatif dire on a
compris on a compris les cieux on a
compris les sentiments de d'asymétrie
peut-être même deux voilà inégalité de
traitement mais c'est pas du tout il
faut pas du tout en vouloir à certains
segments de population c'est ce qui ne
se passe malheureusement c'est ça le
drame aussi d'ailleurs d'en vouloir des
personnes supposées avantagé mais des
choses se sont passées comme ça non il
faut réparer les plaies des personnes
qui ont été abusés c'est ça le grain des
grands enjeux de la puissance politique
qui se fout totalement de ça mais que
nous en tant que collectivité vers
lequel nous devons aller mais quand je
parle de rejet de l'autre avant de venir
aux actions concr étiez si tu es
d'accord c'est que c'est un phénomène de
brutalisation de dun ninth inning de
deux ligues du lol quand même bien
arriver à vouloir humilier du lol
en train de nom en tout cas tous leurs
milliers les autres de dera recèle bon
enfin tout tout tout cet environnement
là j'ai pensé ces derniers temps
à une chose
comment avons-nous maintenant
majoritairement
à l'information pas exclusivement mais
majoritairement à l'information que le
coc vide et que le confinement n'a fait
que va faire qu'amplifier je vais
revenir sur ça on ya à faire
principalement à l'écran via les écrans
et les écrans il ya des claviers dessus
alors soit sur des claviers virtuels
comme on dit de façon erronée soit les
claviers donc ça induit des nouvelles
modes des nouvelles modalités de lecture
c'est à dire c'est faudrait trouver un
autre mot ou qualifier autrement ses
modalités lecture c'est à dire au moment
même on voit en fait immédiatement
réagir
on peut immédiatement et dans la
réactivité plus de devises s'est pas
c'est pas le c'est à dire que on est
dans ce que je disais tout à l'heure en
lit mineur présentation mimi c'est le
temps réel une sorte de temps réel c'est
à dire qu'on réagit au moment même c'est
sale temps réel à 20 pour d'un point de
vue technique c'est d'avoir affaire au
phénomène au moment même où ils ont lieu
que les opérations ont lieu au moment
même où on peut avoir accès aux
résultats des équations moi je tapais un
mot sur word ça tousse opérant tauriel
je vois mon mot voiture en temps réel
voilà c'est sale dorian
tocsin de vie quelque chose qui
s'approche pas de ce temps là mais d'une
d'un rétrécissement de distance entre
les phénomènes il nous est pas seulement
les phénomènes entre les paroles et
paroles de l'autre et notre capacité à
pouvoir les intégrer les lits réfléchir
alors que nous venons historiquement
dano d'une autre modalité de lecture et
ça pour voir que ça induit c'est pour ça
qu'il faut pas tout le temps parler de
l'addiction etc j'ai presque envie dire
ça c'est des petits problèmes les
problèmes petit bourgeois l'addiction
j'en pouvais plus - moment petit faut
voir ce que ça induit d'un point de vue
comportemental et civilisationnel et
politique parce que ces politiques ce
que je vais dire là le livre
le livre c
c'est l'autre c'est la parole de l'autre
que j'accueille que j'accueille que
j'accueille dans quoi dans une
temporalité propre qui appelle la
réflexion qui appelle quand je dis
quelque chose je dis quelque chose de
lever la tête
qui activent l'esprit critique la
contradiction le lien à l'autre pas son
intelligence et mon intelligent la
possibilité d'en faire peur donc là
c'est un rapport à l'altérité
où j'ai envie de dire qu'il ya lieu d'en
dans sa plus grande noblesse la lecture
via les écrans
cessé de la lecture mais c'est un avis
d'autres mécanismes qui au bout du
compte n'induisent pas que cela
attention hein induisent avec ses à
l'information possibilité de créer des
liens avec d'autres mais induisent et
notamment par les plateformes d'accès de
l'expressivité et le fait on partage que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure immédiatement tu
réagis et l'autre il réagit comme ça et
je les insulte ou je dis ah oui tu as
raison et tout cela donne sur de grand
bouillonnement de culture où on est dans
la veine satisfaction de soi
improductives violé dix
sept c5 vie des nouveaux rapports à
autrui on peut comprendre la
brutalisation des échanges
interpersonnels le rejet détruit la
consolidation de nos propres paroles
notamment par la temporalité des
réactivité comme les chaînes d'info qui
ont lieu en direct il ya quelque chose
où tout a lieu voilà d'un effet de
direct donc cela suppose veut dire ce
que je dis là que celle de ses notre
horizon notre horizon à autrui notre
horizon commun ne pas connaître nos
facultés pas seulement faire parler nos
nos affects mais dans des postures
critique élaborait de compréhension et
moi là où je
vraiment ces premiers si tu es d'accord
avant qu'on parle des actions concrètes
ce qui s'est passé avec le co lead c'est
plusieurs catastrophes et c'est
notamment la stratégie du choc de naomi
klein ce que je dis dans ma tribune qui
est parue dans libération
télétravail 2.2 l'accès à l'excès
tu te souviens sky de ce livre de l'âge
de l'accès de jeremy rifkin qui n'était
pas un très bon livre mais il avait noté
quelque chose on était dans l'axé l'axé
plein de choses tu voulais pas dire que
l'accès à internet mais l'accès des
biens de location et c'est quelque chose
de plus léger de moi et aujourd'hui nous
sommes arrivés à l'air de l'excès de
l'excès un voile à l'âge de l'accès
générer des formes de toutes sortes
d'accès avec des franchissements de
seuil on a du mal à y voir clair où nous
affecte parle continuellement mais c'est
pas seulement ça c'est que
le vide et le confinement des logiques
se sont imposés à nous du jour au
lendemain n'est ce pas là une décision
pour la france et pour plein d'autres
pays macron qu'il s'y marge dit je crois
disait de continuer à aller dans le
théâtre et je crois que c'est le 16 mars
au 13 mars je sais plus a dit en mettant
en confinement donc ça nous a été pris
de court est mort de rire bon il ya des
border on l'a vu arriver depuis le 11
janvier la communauté nous avait
prévenus ou d'ailleurs on les salue on a
beaucoup de personnes qui sont en chine
qui nous regardent ils nous ont prévenus
de ce qui était en train de se passer en
chine et nous voyez macro mais c'était
surréaliste
on peut pas reprocher au pouvoir
politique après il ya eu plein de dérive
de plateau n'est de toute évidence tout
le monde attaque ne s'appelle pas
tâtonner ça s'appelle et criminel bon tu
penses au port pour certains pour
certains dossiers je te suis mais bon on
a tâtonné d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a vu
c'est assez intéressant tout de suite du
rebond dit mais je vais revenir à mon
effet c'est qu'au moment même où
notamment via l'intelligence on veut
maîtriser tous les phénomènes du monde
le retour du refoulé on a et on a vécu
une expérience de débordement des
capacités de maîtrise qui devrait nous
rappeler à nos devoirs en société plutôt
que de vouloir tout sécuriser tout
coincé avoir un rapport continue de
visibilité en temps réel des phénomènes
pourquoi pour toujours contrôler les
choses asseoir une maîtrise sur les
choses peut-être serait-il temps et
c'est ça que ça nous arrivait
de nous soucier de la vulnérabilité
d'une société plutôt que de vouloir tout
contrôler notamment par l'intelligence
artificielle de nous soucier de quelque
chose qui nous regardent au premier chef
ne sommes mortels nous l'avons vu nous
sommes fragiles ô combien à tous les
sens du terme nous sommes fragiles
psychiquement
le corps ni no no no ou presque nous
notre capacit nos capacités à encore
espérer nos enfants nous sommes dans des
sociétés de parents parfaits de
vulnérabilité et c ô combien éloquent
faut pas s'en réjouir mais c'est
évidemment qu'il faut pas seulement les
joueurs mais c'est ô combien éloquent de
voir qu'au moment où un moment de
l'histoire de l'humanité mais comme
jamais ce carré comme jamais le
contraste le crédit social en chine
c'est ça c'est ça l'intelligence
artificielle dont nous avions parlé au
delà de tous les discours qui nous lui
qui nous loue l horizon lumineux
économiques à venir grâce et
intelligence artificielle c'était quoi
c'était le projet d'instaurer une une
sur rationalisation de la société via
via des structures techniques et via de
l'investissement public et privé privé
on s'en fiche mais mes publics en vue de
voilà de d'asseoir cette maîtrise est ce
que c'est pas un autre projet politique
et civilisationnel de nous soucier et
dans nos actions de de prendre en charge
nos vulnérabilités
là nous avons vécu aussi cela mais nous
n'avons pas vécu que cela pour revenir
au confinement
sur ce que tu as dit je te laisse la
libre parole évidemment à ce que tu as
dit qu'ils souhaitent criminelle ça
pourrait faire l'objet de débats moi je
pense qu'on a vécu surtout c'est la
confirmation d'une désorientation
collective d'erreurs voilà mais tous les
politiques sont des erreurs n'est ce pas
tous là ils sont à fond assure massive
bon mais moi je peux venir au coeur la
sueur et après si tu veux on parle à
l'action et peut-être qu'il faudra
conclure
nous avons été pris de court
donc des procédés des modalités
notamment dans le cas du travail de
l'enseignement se sont imposés à nous
qui a été nommé
télétravail
apprentissage à distance foncez pas
prendre si sage cours à distance mais
aussi les relations interpersonnelles
qui d'un seul coup la numérisation de
nos existences call of depuis une
vingtaine d'années a connu un brusque
franchissement qui a vu les rapports
interpersonnels
s'opérer de façon quasi exclusive
via des écrans c'est ce que j'ai nommé
dans ma tribune dans libé pour voir des
toiles en accès libre un pour ceux que
ça intéresse une unité qui a été traduit
en espagnol qui peut l'être dans die
welt en allemagne la dent après demain
une télé socialité une télé socialité
généralisée
et selon des modalités c'est à cette
aune qu'il faut comprendre les
rassemblements durant cet été le besoin
de proximité charnel
le fait que cela ne confirme que les
formes de distance pour l'entente
dissociation physique que nous avons
vécu c'est comme ça mais de distance
habilité sur ce que je disais sur la
lecture sky tout à leur habilité à
amplifier les effets de surdité
croissante entre les différentes que
corps composantes du corps social et
nous allons probablement si nous ne
prenons pas garde vers des modalités
intersubjective
via les écrans est là il faut savoir que
le monde économique
quant aux frères quantité de solution à
cela il faut que dans le monde du
travail au delà de tous les discours
forgé ce que je dis dans ma tribune
qu'on nous fasse part des retours
d'expérience du témoignage comment les
choses se sont passées durant le
confinement il ya eu plein de
difficultés par le télétravail est
certes le télétravail peut nous aider
jusqu'à un moment mais quand on s'en
sortira de cette calamité faudrait pas
que ça soit entérinée parce qu'il faut
voir tous les effets sur sur les psys
quai et notamment d'abord les nouvelles
plateformes et les nouveaux
perspectives économiques que ça va que
ça va instaurer des nouveaux chiffres
d'affaires au détriment de quoi de la
capacité encore à être en commun faire
société à dialoguer elle va alors le
conflit tu comprends quand est on impose
des choses bien télétravail c'est très
difficile de contredire quand on est en
groupe sur le lieu du travail on dit est
ensemble on n'en veut pas c'est pas la
même histoire et tout est à l'avenant
donc il va falloir qu'on soit vigilant
sur en société sur les effets sur les
enfants sur une façon d'être ensemble
parce que le monde numérique le de
l'industrie du numérique va tout faire
pour amplifier mais au détriment de
toutes les conséquences psychologiques
d'être ensemble de besoin d'être avec
l'autre et tout cela car nous vivons un
moment je crois je ne sais pas si je les
dis au point où j'en suis
que j'ai nommé moi c'est un mot c'est
une expression oxymorique ça relève d'un
oxymore dan isolement collectif quelque
chose d'un isolement collectif on en
rien complètement continuellement
renvoyé à nos propositions à nous parole
et à notre propre tristesse car le covin
dos remplis qu'amplifier de ça notre
propre tristesse collective donc au
moment nous vivons un moment de
tristesse collective de désorientation
de volonté de justifier d'avoir des
réparations que nous reste-t-il tu vois
pas un peu les choses au noir la
regarde le confinement chez entièrement
d'accord
il ya des gens qui ont très très mal
vécu qui sont trouvés dans des
situations dramatiques des gamins qui
sont retrouvés dans la situation de
dramatique mais non on a eu beaucoup de
chance
on a pu prendre le temps
discuter avec des gens
échanger des bonnes émotions se serrer
les coudes absolument parler parler
d'eux des névroses engendrés par
l'enfermement absolument ça a été aussi
quelque chose de positif c'est pas bien
évidemment et pas seulement ça il va
falloir de réinventer disait d'une sorte
de contradiction totale macron en avril
je crois en ce extraordinaire de dire ça
qu'est ce que ça veut dire gilles faux
sur toute la ligne
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
prison mais en langage poli qu'est ce
que ça veut dire comme je suis riche ne
prêtent pas à sourire qu'est ce que ça
veut dire il va falloir nourrir il s'est
fait hara kiri en direct quand il n'a
pas passé en direct qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est à dire toute ma doxa
techno libera libéral sous couvert de
jus faux sur toute la ligne et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé le réservoir des
dépenses publiques dont on disait qu'ils
avaient peint sous 1 c'est quand même là
la puissance publique est intervenu ça a
été le cas partout moi j'ai beaucoup
d'amis tu le sais peut-être jusqu'à et
puisque medic sont traduits en espagnol
en amérique du sud ils n'ont pas la
puissance publique il en bave beaucoup
plus que nous il en bave beaucoup plus
crue ils n'ont pas la puissance publique
ils n'ont pas la signature de l'état
pour emprunter sur les marchés à ça tu
as bien raison de dire les choses en ces
termes il n'ya pas les qualifications la
france ou pas s'ils allaient en trois
heures actuellement enfin bon et puis on
transporte enfin ça on le sait
l'argentine le défaut enfin bon donc ça
c'était un désaveu
donc au moment où nous sommes dans cette
conscience
on est dans dernier moment la sq a rien
n'est ce pas on va parler de l'action
c'était d'accord je te laisse 20 minutes
ben cheffaj c'est formidable si les gens
sont encore la communauté saint cardio
et est encore prête à me
à supporter nos échanges pendant 20
minutes c'est formidable parce que là où
il faut enchaîner ca il faut enchaîner
sur un autre monde quand je dis il faut
en appeler à notre nom à la hanche et
non sur cet autre sur cet autre moment
ensemble
quand je parle de de conscience
là encore je vais pas me faire que des
amis
la conscience écologique
c'est très bien
mais quand ça occupe ça devient ça fait
écran à toutes les autres questions au
moins aussi important que ça commence à
me gêner sérieusement
car il est évidemment il n'y a pas que
nos corps et nos psys qu'est la
biosphère la terre nos corps aussi avec
les pesticides tout ce qu'on sait mais
avez-vous remarqué il faut se méfier
aussi aux doxa 2,8 dominante quand même
elles sont légitimes il ne faut pas que
ça fasse écran sur les banlieues en
déshérence faux pas sa phase écran
aux difficultés de l'école publique faut
pas que ça fasse écran au drame que
j'étais à toulouse il ya trois jours
j'ai parlé à la série à l'issue d'une
signature à la librairie ombres blanches
avec une psychologue du travail je l ai
je peux aider une femme très gentil
donnez moi votre adresse mal ce que je
vous dis pendant dix ans madame je peux
vous poser une question ces dix
dernières années ça s'est aggravé les
souffrances à la regarder comme ça on me
dit vous n'imaginez pas vous ni mais en
disant vous n'imaginez pas donc tu
comprends la conscience écologique c'est
très bien il faut être agissant et pas
seulement d'ailleurs faire des posts
machin machin va continuellement
avec le paradoxe comment relier un
barreau alors ça qui n'arrête pas de la
ramener sur twitter ou sur facebook avec
ses poches continual réchauffement
climatique ah il en produit du
réchauffement climatique avec ces postes
continue elle peut pas avoir une
attitude parfaite tout le temps mais je
ne dis pas ça et je dis qu'à un moment
faut avoir conscience de nos
contradictions il faut à un moment faut
faire le constat d'une contradiction il
faut aussi rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar il ya un bar où il ya quand même
beaucoup vrie pour la prise de
conscience si tu veux mais quand je vois
moi j'ai rien contre eux sur le garçon à
nous mais nous prenons pas ne nous
méprenons pas mais quand je vois qu'ils
usent de twitter de youtube et de
facebook comme instance de communication
majeur là aussi j'ai envie de dire tu
vois pas une petite contradiction non tu
crois pas qu'on pourrait peut-être
plutôt que faire une tribu d'une part
dont une pétition dans le monde avec
juliette binoche il n'est plus jamais
comme chez bac coûte franchement le
pitti sionisme les flux du présent ou
les flux des fils d'actualité ou les
oubliés du présent moi j'appelle vois
pas ça comme un cheval de troie moi je
vois ça comme une vanité excessive
extrême qui ne mène nulle part pavani
tout non mais je ne parle pas de
barreaux là mais si tu veux on va pas
s'égarer avec barreaux parce que moi
j'ai des choses plus importantes à dire
je signale juste je vais pas dire en
toute amitié parce que c'est pas le
terme là pour le coup en toute
intelligence que
la ram n'est pas ce que c'est cela
ramener ce barreau il a des centaines de
laïcs qui doit être content je pense
qu'il n'est pas privé dégommer comme
nous tous un jeu abstrait pas de ça
qui fait des postes quotidien ce que
j'ai vu un moment cédé post quotidien
très satisfait mais ça tout ça ça
produit du réchauffement climatique mais
ces gêneurs et puis ça entretient le
modèle que c'est via ses interfaces
qu'il faut qu'il faut faire valoir nos
opinions jusqu'à quand tu as parlé
conscience prise de conscience carrie
des années 2015 se met très bien on va
dire très bien mais en 2020 elle s'est
suffi arrêtons arrêtons donc on passe à
ce moment là ce moment-là majeur décisif
qui nous regardent tous la traduction en
actes la traduction politique de
convictions de nos souffrances
de nos trop plein de notre extrême
saturation dont nous n'avons pas parlé
je m'aperçois qu'on a pas parlé du fait
majeur de ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est
à dire le phénomène d'ingouvernabilité
permanente qui est extrêmement périlleux
qu'est ce que je nomme la gouvernabilité
permanente c'est que le fait que
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est l'ère de
ronds points c'est des cas une décision
prise par des pouvoirs politiques
qu'elles soient apparemment
marginal comme la hausse des prix de du
gazole en demi en octobre 2010 vite pour
une taxe supposé écologique ça déchaîne
ddd à juste titre des foules sur dans
les dents dans les rues dans les villes
moyennes dans les ronds-points de france
très bien donc fort mise c'est cela la
gouvernabilité permanente c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui comme chili place à des
italiens qui est pas une place un rond
point je suis allé en janvier os d'un
ticket de métro s'est terminée n'importe
quelle mesure jugée qui confirmera le
fait que trop c'est trop c'est le fait
que maintenant tous les politiques sur
son sont sur des brasiers et macron à
mon sens incarne le moment de 7,1
gouvernabilité le premier président de
la gouvernabilité permanente qu'elle dit
passé denner de jupiters les années
2007-2010 7 jusqu'au gilet jaune où il
paraît totalement sûr jouer et
totalement égarés à y voir de les voir
de plus près donc la gouvernabilité
permanente alten moins de deux choses je
fais venir vraiment c'est promis dans
quelques instants l'action est que
depuis que l'émission 12h20 ça m'a
rassuré à témoin de deux choses
une perte deux fois que je crois moi
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
définitive à l'égard de toute parole
politique
définitive mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire toute parole politique ça veut dire
que même les partis dits anti système
dont on peut supposer ou dit dégage is
comme mélenchon design période dont on
peut soupçonner que même serait vite
enclin mitterrand temps de la rigueur
c'est vous hollande le changement c'est
maintenant utiliser alors la
consolidation de ce qui s'est passé
avant c'était parfait plutôt que le
changement c'est maintenant quelle que
soit même les parties supposé dit dégage
east part comme par un atavisme
indécrottable comme on dit de façon
familière ou et bien serait appelé à se
reproduire et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
de très marquant de très parlant avec
les gilet jaune c'est dès qu'il ya eu
volonté de récupération politique
personnes ont dit non tu te souviens
tout le monde a dit on ne veut pas parce
que l'idée maintenant c'est que chacun
ait sa il faut l'entendre cette
expression chacun
entend seulement parlé en son propre nom
du fonds de ses souffrances du fond de
ses colères du fond de sa situation
professionnelle ou du fond de sa misère
j'ai envie d'y ou du fonds d'exécuter
des approches de son porte-monnaie
arguant du fait nous entérinons le fait
qu'on n'y croit plus alors tu te rends
compte qu est ce que ça veut dire
contrat social de rousseau qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pacte politique dont on a
parlé à l'entâme ça veut dire
adhésion d'un ensemble le corps
politique à un horizon ou à des horizons
ça peut être plus rien c'est plurial il
ya un horizon copains ou un horizon
commun à quelques principes fondamentaux
mais quand on se dit que tout ça ne nous
a amenés que nous les haies et à nous
conduire à des souffrances pour la
majeure partie d'entre nous si il
s'opère quoi une des liaisons entre le
je et le nous entre chacun d'entre vous
et le corps communs et l'ensemble
collectif c'est ça que je nomme dans mon
livre la fin d'un monde commun donc
leleu et ça c'est une catastrophe
bernard stiegler comme nous pouvons nous
mouvons souligné enfin rappelé la
mémoire aujourd'hui
que quelqu'un j'avais pour lequel
j'avais beaucoup d'estimé nous
connaissions de loin nous ne partagions
pas beaucoup enfin pour certaines choses
nous avions l'occasion le même constat
mais sur certaines choses mais divergent
notamment sur le pharmakon l'ambiguïté
des technologies sait pas on n'a pas le
temps d'en parler là mais il parlait
souvent de catastrophe bernard stiegler
bernard j'en parle avec son prénom en
toute amitié il en parlait souvent et
parfois et souvent à juste titre nous
vivons ça c'est une catastrophe c'est à
dire qu'on est arrivé au moment de
l'histoire en société j'ai pas envie
dire en politique parce que c'est pas de
la politique
c'est sale et gilet jaune ça a témoigné
ça il ya eu un moment solidaire ya eu un
moment de fraternité puis a eu un moment
et de fragmentation et puis ça reprend
épisodiquement mais il ya eu de la
difficulté de traduire en actes donc il
y à un moment quand nos moments nous en
arrivons à ne pouvoir et ça veut dire
aussi lesdits réseaux sociaux quand je
dis ça à ne parler qu'en nous propres
nous en notre propre nous à plusieurs
niveaux tu comprends bien sky à ne
parler qu'en notre propre nom c'est une
catastrophe politique c'est le signe
d'un échec et là c'est le coeur de la
fère et le sait le coeur ça sera l'enjeu
de mon prochain livre parce que là je
suis un diagnostic et je suis une des
choses traduc traduisions politique tu
veux que je te donne quelques clés de là
où j'en suis moyen près et après on
passe aux questions internet très bien
traduire politiquement on va dire que
c'est on a beaucoup parlé on a beaucoup
pris conscience comment traduire il faut
bien mes chers amis là je vais pas dire
mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
quand je dis ça comprendre que c'est des
modestes réflexion propositions qui sont
qu'un appel à chacun a engagé des
propres actions des propres réflexions
des était totalement ouvert notre lance
en politique certainement pas tu va
soutenir quelqu'un en politique pour
l'instant je n'y vais pas en revanche je
vais de plus en plus vers de la
philosophie politique si on n'avait pas
compris que c'est là où j'étais avec mes
livres sur la technique parce que les
catégories techno technophiles tout ça
c'est tellement restreint ce pas du tout
ça me concernant tous mes livres sont
des livres de philosophie politique au
prisme ce qui s'est passé bien l'assaut
du techno libéralisme sur nos vies il ya
eu des réductions de nos capacités
politiques c'est en gros ce que tout ce
que je dis là jusqu'à maintenant me
lancer en politique certainement pas en
revanche analyse est plus que jamais
avec mes outils et mon expérience les
phénomènes du présent parce que j'adore
ça aussi j'adore et je suis une éponge
je vois les choses laissant bart à la
foire de paris dalil vois ça j'adore
voir ça parfois je m'en désole puis
quand j'ai des expériences je vais à
comprendre dedans et puis que c'est une
fois jouer au hockey puis quand c'est
tous les jours et puis je vois des gens
s'engueuler ils ont aucune raison on
voit bien qu'il sait quelque chose
contre un ordre plus grand que chacun de
nous qui s'exprime dans ses colères dans
ses ressentiments là je me dis il faut
continuer à analyser et à même juste
mesure et c'est le cas là je le montre
de ce livre de donner des clés de si je
peux d'intelligibilité mais pas de
saignement d'intelligibilité je
réfléchissais beaucoup réfléchi avec ou
lors de mon dernier livre hélas cette
quantité de notes que je prends depuis
des années et pour mon prochain livre
comment on peut re politisé après le
moment de la fapa après parce qu'il est
pas après un moment de la conscience
parallèlement la conscience comme
empereur politise alors je crois que là
c'est le couteau suisse
c'est le couteau suisse n'y a pas de
modalités unique d'abord il faut être
agissant et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
agissant à mon sens c'est ça se fait
appeler ça doit ça devrait dès
maintenant sans attendre se déployer du
diverses manières d'abord faire pression
sur le pouvoir politique sur les
institutions pour
renouer avec le pack mais sa pression
que moi alors je vais te dire renoue
avec le pack mais ça ça veut pas dire
grand chose il faut surtout en appeler
j'avais écrit une tribune sur cela parce
que dès que je suis pris par un assaut
de colère je crie une tribu s'appelait
pas une politique de témoigner acheté
par vue je crois dans libé en mode avril
pour une politique du témoignage je
crois que là il faut écouter la réalité
du terrain là la puissance publique
plutôt que les experts qui arrêtent pas
de pression sur alors je continue
bertrand scary pardon plus plutôt que la
dent mais tout le monde connaît
aujourd'hui enfin bref plus tu excuse
moi plutôt que c'était mais c'est le
coeur qui a parlé parce que tu sais on
sait que les gens ont compris nous
sommes amis aussi hein c'est pas juste
une interview alain cariou l'amitié
c'est important l'amitié dans les vies 1
si je suis là c'est pas un hasard nous
sommes amis parce que nous construisons
des choses en a mis en scène chacun avec
ses outils et donc nous en sommes
la pression
témoignage nous avons trop nous sommes
trop laissé aller à adouber les paroles
d'expert quand vous faites des ddd des
réunions en entreprise et les experts
qui parle et des experts patentés
rémunéré par l'industrie c'est pareil
pour les écoles la numérisation du lycée
de l'école publique c'est croiser ton
avis des experts sont allés voir
l'inspection at elle dit académique
sécurisation l'hôpital et de l'eau
qu'est ce que c'est t'inquiète pas
qu'est ce que c'était et tout à
l'avenant c'est des experts qui ont
vendu des solutions comme dit l'autre
des solutions en vue de ces du lobbying
c'est le résultat de lobbying il serait
temps de faire valoir une politique
d'abord du témoignage là où les plaies
de la société se font sentir les écoles
tu en parles et sky ces sinistrés
comment fait-on pas entendons les
professeurs plutôt que d'entendre le duo
responsable de microsoft en en 2014 avec
la la ministre d'hollande excusez moi je
n'arrive jamais dire son nom à jo bats
le jeu n'arrive jamais john van hummel
qui ont à nous dire microsoft c'est
formidable et les tablettes numériques
et si on avait écouté plutôt que les
experts de microsoft et d'industrie
limery les professeurs en difficulté
dans l'école publique est ce que si la
puissance publique avait écouté le
manque de moyens locaux exigus ça coûte
cher certes mais c'est un projet de
société c'est un projet politique si
dans le monde de l'entreprise ça c'est
pour moi tu le sais on en a parlé la
dernière fois pour moi quelque chose qui
me tient totalement à coeur et qui
devrait tous nous tenir à coeur et
notamment les syndicats voudraient pas
se soucier que de pouvoir d'achat même
si c'est au combien ennemis éminemment
important la question du porte-monnaie
aujourd'hui plus que jamais je dois avec
ce qui nous attend ce qui nous attend
bon mais le management ça suffit france
télécom qui disait que c'était génial
leur mode c'était des ordures excusez
moi je suis en fin de l'entretien c'est
le coeur qui parle les mecs c'était des
ordures y sont au pénal la franco qu'un
appel anonyme ces criminels et c'était
des discours forget c'est formidable
c'est pour la transition lors dé vous
entendez transition faut se méfier
la transition commander la transition
numérique des cas transition faut faire
une transition écologique pareil c'est
toute la transition avec les solutions
vertes etc carbone et tout ce que bon
faut faire très attention la transition
parce que transition ça veut dire ça
peut aussi vouloir dire vos acquis vendu
à la poubelle la traite et puis des
modes au club des modes existants ce cas
l'on tient ça va à la poubelle autant le
monde du travail qu'on nous raconte je
l' ai dit la dernière fois avec toi sky
le monde du travail
intelligence artificielle qu'on nous
raconte des entrepôts à mesure qu'on
nous raconte génial intelligence
artificielle les signaux où tu vas selon
des cadences infernales de d'endroit en
endroit ça épuise les corsa et puis les
esprits c'est génial comme disait
villani il faut encore plus
d'intelligence artificielle pour
organiser ce modèle de société est
maintenant il dit on va faire un peu de
sobriété numérique 1 comme quoi les élus
donc les gens n'ont pas peur de leurs
contradictions c'est pas grave faute
avouée à demi pardonnée dit on n'est ce
pas bon donc les témoignages mais il
faut pas seulement ça témoignage dans
mon couteau suisse l'heure est à la fête
aux réparations il faut qu'ils du flic
je suis désolé de dire les choses de
façon familière et brut pour les
banlieues il faut qu'ils du fric tu as
entendu les mines en vo non je vais je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable ou jour
versé dans le monde du fric dont évoluer
bébé c'est pas con anvers tu te souviens
de borloo le plan david il y avait des
belles intentions à un moment
il faut qu'une politique pas seulement
de la ville une politique des
populations
des classes et défavorisées qui se
sentent humiliés et qui vont faire si
nous n'y prenons garde les générations
qui viennent mais l'ingouvernabilité
permanente on risque d'aller vers ce que
moi je nomme dans mon livre une barbarie
ordinaire
invoquer dieu mais barbarie ordinaire au
sens des meilleurs sentiments qui parle
ou c'est la violence qui parle des
nouvelles formes de violence qui
s'exprime par le fait de ceux d'avoir
l'illusion ou le sentiment mais comme un
échec de se faire justice soi-même
contre un ordre plus grand que soi c'est
un échec donc ya urgence il ya le feu il
ya le feu c'est pas seulement borloo
politique de la ville et que tu manges
été interrompu ce qui arrive mais je
termine juste ça et après excuse moi
mais mais il ya urgence à ce qu'il y ait
de l'argent public
mais là avec tout si c'est déjà le cas
mais pas suffisamment tu as vu ce que
les misérables de la dgi l'année le free
mettez moi j'ai trouvé forme et même le
film on a le temps même si on prend cinq
minutes de plus pas grave c'est moi qui
prend le nom mais
déjà formellement le fils justin louis
que tu viens de cette parole qui dit
ils expriment leur peau leur collent
leur colère est ce qu'il ya une autre
moyen aujourd'hui d'exprimer leur que de
casser faut l'entendre cette phrase dans
les misères donc il faut pareil les
plaies je vais te léger excuse moi de
prendre la parole là mais quand je dis
réparer des plaies les manuels scolaires
et paraît l'hôpital réparer parce qu'on
en bave tous ce n'est pas le personnel
la campagne réparer aussi la biosphère
quelqu'un à la campagne la biosphère
le gamin qui vit à marly gomont avec les
vaches et qui a pas de connexion
internet correct qui laissait sans
transport en commun qui se retrouve avec
un système éducatif qui a pas d'hôpital
pour espérer charcuter les dents
à tout les sites l'heure est aux
situations à la prise en compte à la
prise en charge de la puissance publique
et c'est là que nous devrons d'abord peu
la pression mais ça ne suffit de
puissance publier ça que j'ai fait un
genou alors mais non mais non je te dis
simplement les choses les gilet jaune
les les mouvements manifestation ça
quand même produit quelque chose enfin
ça produit beaucoup de choses notamment
des liens de solidarité des effets de
conscience parce qu'on a vu en creux un
visage de la france qui était ignorée
c'est ça qui va s'y passer dorénavant à
paris comment qui était ignoré
uniquement par paris qui a été ignorée
par pari par les politiques par les
médias par un très grand nombre de et
qu'on n'avait pas su voir et dont on
n'avait pas su prendre la mesure
mais ça aussi produit des choses et un
moment la puissance publique mais c'est
pareil dans d'autres pays regardent que
cela produit au chili un référendum
remettre en cause la constitution qui
date quand même de la dictature de 7,2
ce criminel hors la voilà un criminel de
ceux de pinochet voilà donc un moment il
ya de la pression sur le pouvoir
politique par la manifestation par
l'insatisfaction parfois aussi le faux
il ya des moments comme ça tant qu'il
n'est pas sûr personne que la question
de la violence aujourd'hui décisive
quelle nature de violents et qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait de cette violence est elle
témoigne de quoi mais pas seulement
elles témoignent de quoi jusqu'à quel
point il peut être légitime fut pression
que mou alors gelé alors mais comment ça
on fait pression comme
comment ce carré les gilet jaune c'était
une pression il ya eu des actes concrets
il ya eu des acquis quelques acquis
quelques avancées mais ça ne suffit pas
la pression et doit être permanente aldo
est permanente elle doit d'abord l'idée
de favoriser les projets politiques à
l'opposé si on peut les qui croire parce
qu'il nous avait vendu sa hollande et
limitant aussi nous avait déjà vendu ça
il ya bien longtemps qu'ils qui
favorisent encore tous les cas qui
proclame ou qui promettent l'application
de modèles plus vertueux mais c'est pas
seulement ça parce que nous sommes dans
une situation aussi qui nous a pris au
piège où on attend tous on attend trop
où il faut attendre jusqu'à une certaine
mesure du pouvoir politique à
l'intérieur de structures pyramidales
alors que nous vivons l'heure des
réseaux depuis une vingtaine d'années
alors que nous comprenons qu'il ya des
nouvelles modalités démocratique qui
soit se mettre en place nous avons
besoin d'institutions dans les pays en
grands noms peut-être qu'en suisse ou
dans des petits quand on peut avoir des
démocraties beaucoup plus d'y aller nous
avons besoin d'institutions donc pour
que l'institution une pression mais qui
doit être permanente c'est de ne pas
s'en laisser à notre liberté négative
c'est-à-dire à se soucier de notre seul
problème et puis une fois que ces
réseaux
l'ensemble commun et des enjeux
politiques qui nous regardent tous
soient soient ignorées mais ça veut dire
aussi ne pas ne pas d'abord tout
attendre du sommet alors que nous sommes
dans des haies des jeux de plus en plus
horizontale is et des rapports entre les
personnes ça veut dire qu'il faut
prendre en compte les nouvelles les
nouvelles procédures démocratiques se
sont mises en place dans les grandes
démocraties six mois des drones dans
procédures démocratiques dans les
magazines mais je pense par exemple aux
collectivités locales à la
décentralisation en france il faut faire
il faut en appeler pas seulement au sens
à la sempiternelle figure mais quasi
pien du président de la république
espérons le un jour d'une présidente de
la république pas contents qu'on veut
des évolutions vertueuse s'est enquis
alternance pas seulement gauche droite
mais aussi homme femme et puis tout ce
qu'on veut dans termes d'alternance
possible et inimaginable et quelqu'un
qui vient devant lui un jour si on on
veut rêver plus larges comme on dit
comme disait hugo un peu l'appel au
large qu'on appelle au large au delà de
nos cadres restreint et ô combien
étouffant mais aussi sur les
collectivités locales à pourquoi je dis
les collectivités locales et là je fais
le lien avec le dernier point de
l'action sur le terrain parce que leur
leur est sur le terrain de save pour moi
c'est un point d'eux mais vraiment
décisif auquel je pense des années que
je vais théorisé précisément
leur état je vais j'avais parlé du refus
l'année dernière la dernière fois le
pouvoir du refus je pense que le pouvoir
poser ligne 1 de dire non nous n'en
avons pas assez usés il ya des moments
dans nos existences si des preuves voit
des choses moi je dis je donne souvent
des conférences dans des lycées ou des
profs ou dans les entreprises des profs
voit des choses alors on veut garder
notre boulot tu disais
ce cas rien c'est vrai il ya des membres
sinon ça suffit la saturation c'est à
dire ça suffit d'un ordre ça il suffit
de choses qui se mettent ça suffit non
c'est pas avec votre dock ça mais quand
tu comprends qu'on est non seulement une
chose qu'on et non en plusieurs saveurs
la fin d'un monde comme nom rayé vivait
un monde commun raviver l'action en
commun dans l'entreprise vous saloperies
que vous mettez en place vos modes de
management je te jure enfin je te jure
qui suis-je pour dire je te jure on peut
supposer ensemble que si des personnes
entre les caves ait pu avoir conscience
ou comprendre et qui avaient des effets
de solidarité d'être ensemble écoute de
l'autre si à france télécom en
2007-2008 des souffrances et des
procédés qui se mettait en place hélas
les galas des responsables à nouveau de
vos solutions ça suffit non seulement ça
suffit on va le dénoncer on va écrire
des tribunes on va aller s'exprimer dans
les médias et on va faire des
manifestations équipe quitte à ce qu'on
va faire des collectifs
auprès des actions collectives auprès de
la justice car nous avons aussi ce
pouvoir en démocratie de faire des
actions collectif au pénal en justice il
y a donc déjà le pouvoir de dire non
pier paolo pasolini voire du reçu de
dire non à mobiliser mais il le pouvoir
de l'action positive alors je crois on
l'a dit pression auprès des ddd de
l'institution
encourager des modes et des programmes
vertueux si y en a mais il ya la
défiance donc c'est compliqué parce que
nous vivons une atomisation de la
société c'est pour ça qu'on sent très
bien que la prochaine présidentielle on
sait pas où on va personne peut dire ça
va être un tel qu on sait très bien
c'est que moi je ne parle mais on va pas
je veux pas parler de sabre dans
l'actualité présente sa mère a voté quoi
sa manière la fonction je les dis je
l'exigé une question juste que je devais
passer tout de suite selon lui la
démocratie est-elle capable de résister
aux changements qui viennent si elle
n'est pas déjà cédé à l'autoritarisme et
est ce que la france qui vote peut créer
un nouveau monde alors je lis je l' ai
répondu plus ou moins la france qui
votent elle doit pouvoir mais encore
faut-il écouter la valeur de 2,2 le
programme de programmes qui inverserait
l'ordre des choses mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils en aient qu'il soit
sincère complices y croire mais la
démocratie c'est pas que c'est pas que
le vote c'est ça qu'on a
vous savez et la personne qui pose la
question
peut-être cette idée certainement que
notamment dans les sciences humaines
depuis une dizaine d'années de par le
monde et beaucoup en france il ya
quantité de travaux mais aussi dans
l'expérimentation local de travaux qui
réfléchissent mais pas seulement des
travaux théoriques à nous ressaisir
collectivement de nos existences et ça
passe par ça et là la démocratie jeu pas
comme en avait appelé cela ségolène
royal en 2007 qui était très très mal
formulé ce n'était pas assez précis mais
la démocratie participative
on pourrait dire un autre mot c'est la
démocratie radicale selon john dewey
dont je vais parler puisque je sais que
tu as les usages ici le joli visage que
vous avez de te demander trois livres de
john de john dewey de grands grands
philosophes politiques posent une
question ouais mais mais de parler de
demeurer non mais c'est pas pour un
livre là je dis points une notion de
démocratie radicale
démocratie a dit qu'est ce que ça veut
dire démocratie c'est pas un ordre
politique radicale c'est pas un
autoritarisme c'est tout le contraire
démocratie radicale voulant dire que
tout ce qui peut faire office de levier
démocratique soit mise en branle soit
mise en action alors pourquoi je dis ça
parce que là je m'aperçois que j'ai
toujours pas dit le coeur de mon iphone
c'est de construire mais la sky nous en
avons déjà parlé
lors de mon dernier passage chez les
amis de singer view c'est je crois qu'il
faut
mettre en place des modes des nouveaux
modèles là où nous sommes pas seulement
permaculture et comme ce néo qui m'agace
un peu écolo mysticisme qui montrent la
entrant il faut vivre comme les oiseaux
écouter les arbres suivre les loups
alors tu parles du nouveau projet
politique de notre temps on voit bien
suivi les loups tout ouais non mais tu
vois non mais là je sais pas si vous
avez vu comme maintenant c'est devenu
les nouveaux livres à la mode dans les
librairies alors on va vivre comme des
oiseaux bon très bien ok c'est à dire on
aurait eu tout faux tout or nous en tant
qu'être humain non on n'a pas eu tout or
il ya eu d'aidé il ya eu des dérives moi
je veux bien qu'on apprenne des choses
en s'inspirant des oiseaux mais je pense
que d'un point de vue politique on est
dedans on est dans le lhc pas une forme
de fourvoiement pour ça fait très joli
on observe les oisons s'inspire 2 pareil
avec les longs suspendu bio l'élitisme
non non pas du tout venant de certains
livres je peux pas citer je veux pas me
faire des ennemis là parce que c'est pas
des ennemis ça c'est pas du tout des
ennemis c'est je pense qu'on est dans
une nouvelle doxa délirante où il y en a
qui des bouquins il faut suivre les
loups en pleine nuit ce que le gars tu
comprends il a sa maison à la campagne
fait de la table va dire que le nouveau
modèle politique dans les banlieues ou
dans les entreprises ont souvent ce
faire les suivent les loups alors dire
ça ils vont tous faire très bien nouveau
modèle politique vertueuse ou alors ou
alors
de quel est l'olympien j'ai vu trop quoi
donc voilà le oui les arbres alors la
lézarde la végétation c'est
extraordinaire je veux citer personnes
vivent comme les végétaux qui sont en
interaction continue j'ai enseigné aux
injustices au et que le sait très bien
je dis pas qu'on peut pas apprendre de
choses du monde biologique et ô combien
mais si c'est ça le nouvel modèle
politique
qui vivent à s'approcher se régénérer
des arbes la cdu du new age qui ne
ferait que confirmer le 2 qui narre mais
il ya des bouquins de monsieur boutant
du vent les 10 meilleurs albums y en a
beaucoup et je pense que certes c'est
pour ces propositions politiques deux
parties nobles ont beaucoup de bouquins
bon je fais référence par exemple à la
série de
darty qui a eu dans le monde au mois
d'août sur les bancs les penseurs du
nouveau monde alors allez voir qu'ils
sont là mais je veux pas c'était je
n'avais pas prévu non plus non mais moi
j'ai rien contre ces gens là mais qu'on
ne dise pas que c'est le grand projet
politique de notre temps peut-être qu'on
les met en avant pour discréditer
d'autres propositions je n'y a pas de
complot c'est comme ça il ya des effets
de mode ces personnes est vraiment c'est
pas du tout par pour rattraper ce que je
dis c'est ce que font des travaux de
qualité cd crainte de travaux
universitaires de qualité mais qu'on
aille pas à nous dire que le nouveau
modèle de politique de notre temps c'est
de nous inspirer d'aller suivre les lois
parce que vous aviez vu loubon mais on
va pas en parler je vous donnerai les
références d'accord je vous les
donnerais je vous les donnerais les
références ces pros mais c'est promis
mais c'est pas pour encore j'ai rien
contre ces gens là mais il faut quand
même prendre conscience des chevaux
question internet la solution n'est-elle
pas le stoïcisme épices et pister et
puis j'arrive pas à le prononcer les
pistes et
epistem peut-être disait ce qui ne
dépend pas de moi de ma efekta tepic est
merci ce qui ne dépend pas de moi ne
m'affecte pas ne devrions nous pas vivre
selon l'éternel retour de nietzsche
j'entends ce que dit ce monsieur c'est
monsieur
monsieur ils ont
malheureusement non je ne crois pas du
tout si si on si on fait preuve de
stoïcisme relations ya des choses qui
nous regardent différemment parce que ce
soit ici c'est ce sur quoi je ne peux
pas agir je ne fracasse pas le crâne à
vouloir que les choses se passent
autrement c'est tout le contraire la
mission je termine ce qu'il ce sur quoi
nous pouvons être agissant il faut plus
que jamais agir mais avant la prochaine
question je tiens à dire qu agir on a
dit on a décliné ses construire des
nouvelles modalités alors des nouvelles
modalités d enseignement possible de
créer des nouvelles des nouveaux
institutions scolaires mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça avec des personnes
qui réfléchissent tu sais que la
notation a été mise en cause depuis
quelques années est ce qu'il n'ya pas
dans les régions mais partout dans le
monde et pour ce qui est de la france la
puissance publique au lieu de donner du
des subventions pour accueillir amazon
aux toyota qui nous lâchent deux mois
plus tard ou amazon qui détruit le
commerce de proximité et accable les
corps et les esprits des associations
vertueuse qui veulent construire
autrement les choses le soin le soin
l'école nous l'avons dit bref à toutes
les échecs de nos sociétés jeu il me
semble hélas je parlais de john digweed
grand philosophe politique parce qu'avec
tu sais ce qu'il a dit sky avec la
notion très importante
je l'encouragé personnes que ça
intéresse d'aller voir de quoi il s'agit
cette notion de démocratie radicale ils
l'associent à une dimension
c'est l'expérimentation
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'expérimentation ça veut dire il ya des
choses qui ne satisfait ce pas il ya des
limites à certains modèles et on
expérimente pas seulement au niveau en
attendant des gouvernements des
institutions on expérimente sur le
terrain
collectivement c'est sale politique dans
l'action on évalue ensemble l'a
peut-être ça fonctionne pas là il se
passe quelque chose on tente de
l'approfondir de le développer mais
aussi on demande ou en société
et en tant que composantes du corps
politique et ça c'est un point majeur
qu'il y est il ya de l'argent public en
france non dans l'est dans la démocratie
qu'il y ait un soutien pour des
initiatives vertueuse sur le terrain ça
aussi c'est faire office de d'action
politique sur le terrain c'est pas
seulement subir les situations et de
dire on va seulement dire non un peut
tout attendre et attendre des lendemains
qui chantent par des promesses
politiques de programmes plus vertueux
c'est aussi d'engager sur le chemin dans
le cadre de l'action quotidienne des
actions dont 10 sur les organismes comme
ça par l'expérimentation justement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'expérimentation dire qu'on n'a pas la
science infuse on n'a pas raison de tout
mais on se dit selon nos principes au
delà des différends politiques en
groupes en groupes collectivement en
commun en groupe des modalités dans le
travail dans l'école dans le soin d'en
dans les états bordant la façon
d'organiser peut t'aider des cultures
l'alimentation des circuits courts tout
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui on expérimente
on expérimente pas seulement
collectivement à notre niveau on exige
et on construit des mouvements sociaux
pour que tout cela la puissance publique
nous qui donnons des impôts et puissance
publique ce n'est pas une personne une
figure un personnel qui nous qui nous
donnent généreusement de l'argent c'est
un c'était une redis c'est ça aussi la
redistribution qui est la redistribution
pour soutenir ses actions milieu ça nous
ne le faisons pas suivi non seulement
nous ne faisons pas suffisamment mais
nous sommes à l'opposée de l'inflation
discours de l'expression continuelle et
la dénonciation du capitalisme
un air de moulins avarie de moulin à
paroles lassé des actes qu'on gratte de
concret de nous sortirions tous grandi à
plusieurs titres d'abord l'idée de plus
nous être continuellement dans des
impasses de nous impliquer d'être dans
l'action c'est plus des passions tristes
les passions tristes de spinoza dont
avait parlé michel onfray ici des
passions tristes c'est l'inaction c'est
la puissance de l ai parlé
continuellement sénat puissance d'être
dans la joie la joie spinoziste qu'est
ce que c'est c'est d'avoir le sentiment
de se saisir de son propre destin
individuellement et collegia pas de joie
collective mais il pourrait y en avoir
une joie collective et de se saisir dans
l'action de service de son existence
donc c'est cela aussi à l'opposé de
cette inflation disco est dans le
concret des shows 2020 une nouvelle
décennie qui commence moi je dis aime de
modestes mesures au moment après toutes
ces analyses et de chantier que j'ai
encore à mener que la décennie qui nous
incombent qui vient pas qui nous
incombent c'est terrible ce que je dis
qu'ils nous qui s'annonce qui vient à
nous qui nous regardent qui mobilise
notre responsabilité elle va voir une
lutte farouche une lutte très farouche
entre les deux pulsions absolument
opposés n'est ce pas entre thanatos
aeros entre se mue par la pulsion de
détruire de faire parler que leurs
ressentiments et se mue par le principe
d'espérance un livre d'anne ce blog et
la volonté de construire
de construire et
d'imaginer dans l'action autrement en
question n'était possible que la
politique sur le terrain nos vies
quotidiennes je t'écoute pardon je vais
prendre la gazeuse la politique du
compromis dans l'époque actuelle nous
fait-elle perdre tous nos acquis qu'est
ce que ça veut dire un compromis et la
politique du compromis dans l'époque
actuelle nous fait-elle père je
comprends tous nos acquis show comprend
dont mathieu salut
je les dis nous l'avons dit la politique
du compromis on peut dire l'acceptation
la politique de la passivité pense-t-il
du concept du monde d'après
[Rires]
je réponds maintenant la question où tu
veux voir d'autres questions parce que
je peux répondre toujours en amenant des
réponses
ces délais
c'est la passivité je sais plus ce qu'il
dit le d aquila passivité c'est d'action
et le monde d'après plutôt que de nous
soucier toujours avec le discours avait
quantité tribune qui a eu pendant le le
confinement sûr on nous promet des
lendemains meilleurs tout devrait être
autrement du jour au lendemain c'est pas
le monde d'après non il faut se soucier
c'est du monde qui nous a été légué
c'est l'état du monde qui nous a été
légué ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est ça devrait se soucier ça il suffit
les discours futuro logique la
futurologie rendez vous compte qu'on a
vécu pendant le confinement d'un seul
coup on rêver à des quantités d'avenir
c'est très très bien de rêver mais c'est
pas ça à rêver rêver c'est d'abord faire
un diagnostic de l'état des terrains et
de là où nous venons ce que nous avons
fait un peu ce soir et
avant le monde d'après qu'est ce que
c'est que ce monde dans lequel nous
sommes actuellement incluses et aidons
et de nous héritons et dont pour
certains nous l'eau vont avec
ressentiment mais avec avec passivité
voilà donc je reviens à mon affaire
d'action pose encore la question ce
qu'il faut c'est quand même la politique
du compromis dans l'époque actuelle nous
fait-elle perdre tous nos acquis mais
j'ai répondu
la politique de compromis on peut dire
que la politique de
deux d'un suffisamment d'actions peut
dire comme ça le du compromis ou deux
qu'est ce qu'on peut entendre par
compris si j'entends bien là la question
bien sûr bien sûr puisqu'il faut pas il
faut pas faut pas compter sur tout le
monde la doxa néolibérale pour maintenir
les acquis non il faut que tu comprends
quand je dis monde commun ça veut dire
que plus que jamais il faut qu'ils aient
des luttes avait plus que jamais et des
luttes et les buts doivent être farouche
et c'est ça le politique c'est l'agonie
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais les
luttes c'est pas voilà je veux pas
radoter là je ne sais pas les luttes
c'est pas les réseaux sociaux les luttes
c'est l'action et s'opposer et s'opposer
à des violences à des violences là il ya
une question qui pique oui attention
demandé tu m'a interrompu dans ma femme
mais c'est pas ça me gêne pas demandez
lui pourquoi il fait semblant d'être en
tri système alors qu'ils demandent 30000
euros aux écoles pour faire une
conférence soyez en accord vous parle
monsieur sade sait très bien ce qu'il
dit mais je veux dire moi je réponds
j'ai déjà répondu plusieurs fois d'abord
c'est pas trente mille euros quand même
30 bis av bouquenom mais je serais ravi
parce que tout le monde a envie de
gagner des sous c'est pas le plat de
gagner 10 mon problème c'est les hisser
c'est quand on est baisé kankan le
travail qu'on fait n'est pas n'est pas
rémunéré à
sa juste mesure c'est ça le problème
mais alors moi je vais dire de
chaussures cela quand je suis invité en
entreprise ou que des écoles
qui avaient vite peu de posture critique
m'invite je facture je facture car je ne
vis que de mes droits d'auteur j'ai
acquis mon autonomie je ne sais pas pour
combien de temps jacky mon autonomie je
trouve que mes bouquins j'y travaille
pour cela se vendent très bien tant
mieux et je suis souvent invité à des
conférences et il est hors de question
principalement quand ça lui des
entreprises où je fais valoir en toute
liberté ma parole critique que je ne
facture pas à la mesure que j'évalue
moi-même et notamment avec des agences
une agence de communication monsieur que
ça peut très bien avec philippe d'arbois
avec qui j va allumer conférence est qui
te fait fait traquer avec qui travaille
plein de on en veut dire d'auteur
d'écrivains et d'intellectuels
car c'est un usage aujourd'hui d'aller
porter la parole et il n'y a pas de
honte mon cher monsieur parce que ça
frôle la balance qu'il a dit là ça frôle
la balance mais c'est pas grave j'ai de
quoi répondre il n'y a pas de honte cher
monsieur alors que je travaille ce en
étant rémunéré pendant un an deux ans
sur mes lire au moment je fais valoir ma
parole où je n'ai pas été rémunéré
pendant deux ans ou parfois j'ai mon
porte-monnaie plus que c'est vrai qu'au
moment où des personnes manifestent
intérêt à ce que je fais valoir mes
positions et le fruit de mes recherches
que je sois rémunéré à la hauteur que
j'estime et on accepte où on refuse mais
j'ai 9 ans personne en faisant cela
autre question vaut-il mieux suivre les
louer ces liens la balance la formidable
vaut-il voûte ses 30000 ou 33000 et
encore quand c'est dans le secteur
public c'est pas du tout 3000 euros mais
quand c'est orange je vais faire pareil
tu crois que je vais leur faire alors je
suis allée gratuitement je suis ravi
d'être chez vous ils veulent vendre une
part le critique et tout ça va faire
office de comment on dit ça tue c'est de
bonne gestion interne a été ensuite
trois livres et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
question voti faut-il mieux suivre les
loups ou manger les moutons
[Rires]
c'est effrayant danger des moutons ni
l'un ni l'autre ni l'un ni l'autre il
faut à
philanthrôpia
politique de politique de l'amitié
disait jacques derrida 9 hippolyte
philanthrôpia on a perdu sa la filiale
6/10 et stiegler la possibilité de nous
entendant société on a perdu ça c'est
hélas il ya on n'est pas dans un monde
de bergerie de louer de moutons on est
dans un monde où ou allégées par les
croupes de kropotkine tout à l'heure un
seul arrêt qu'est-ce qu'est ce que c'est
que son grand livre de kropotkine duquel
vous connaissez son titre l'entr'aide
voilà mêlant trets est pas là encore
c'est pas des bons sentiments dans près
de l'entrée notre aide ce qui s'est
passé à l'hôpital public c'est donc
trade fair les gens ils ont été payés
miller ils ont fait 37 heures en 24
heures l'entrée à tous les niveaux tous
les niveaux l'entr'aide et c'est donc là
le une seconde la métaphore du loup et
du et du et du mouton une seconde on la
met de côté l'homme est un loup pour
l'homme et ses actes tout c'est toute
cette doxa là qu'on entend depuis des
siècles y loue pouces ouais voilà le
très bien alors une seconde on va la
mettre de côté parce que tout ça
induites sa consigne de conséquence à la
concurrence de tous contre tous voir la
guerre de tous contre tous dont la
puissance politique est supposé nous
enfin tout ça est compliqué mais ça ça
entérine quand même le fait que la
compétition acharnée et le seul modèle
de société
elle peut être faite il inverser les
choses aussi c'est ça l'action c'est
peut-être que dans le socialisme dans
l'anarchie dans l'esprit libertaire il y
avait des choses entre ce donc avait été
un peu ironisé à un moment il ya 20 ans
il ya trente ans il ya 40 ans qui avait
été pris considéré à la marge on est
dans un moment libertaire de nos
sociétés aujourd'hui en tout cas en
terme de conscience je pense qu'on vit
un moment pas majoritaires mais il
montez libertaire de vue le livre de
cette personne que j'ai pas lu mais le
titre ma fille riche parce que vous lui
livre une femme apparemment qui vient du
monde de l'entreprise et qui a dit
comment je suis devenu un archi c'est
extraordinaire quoi je pense que le
bouquin mais nous vivons un moment libre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire nous vivons
un moment libérateur ça veut dire qu'on
n'est pas seulement on ne vit pas
seulement le moment de la revendication
on est dans le moment on peut dire on se
dit ce modèle a échoué mais il a
tellement échoué que c'est par nous
promettons à nouveau de le remettre en
chantier ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est pas seulement à nouveau de le
remettre sur le chantier s'est maintenu
en dix ans la ressource commune qu'est
ce que ça veut dire de ne pas léser les
autres qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'entrée dans les faits d'un concours
qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire
comment on peut organiser ça car ce
modèle libéral s'est pas seulement la
quête du profit c'est toute une série
des modes de modalités d existence qui
nous ont fracassé le crâne des esprits
et des corps qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça c'est à dire que ça nous a éloignés
les uns des autres des zones éloignées
les agressions en tant que capacité de
fer politique donc il est temps aussi
dans vis de nous dire les sempiternelle
promesse là je fais référence à la
campagne 2022 par exemple pour la france
mais on pourrait dire la même chose pour
d'autres pays
peut-être est-il temps d'envisager les
choses par une redéfinition total de la
valeur de ce pacte non pas en nous
disant comme dit gaël giraud par exemple
pour qui j'ai beaucoup de sympathie il
faut plus de puissance publique de
mécanismes solidarité mais qu'est ce que
ça fait ça cette fille quand arrive le
modèle in fine et peut-être que c'est à
la base qui font remettre en cause ce
modèle c'est à dire des devoirs que
toujours à un moment cette équation
noble à l'origine entre liberté
individuelle et bien être commun supposé
il ya toujours un moment il ya des voies
m'en parlent par l'idéologie du mérite
kate qui a été très forte aux états unis
au cours des années 50 avec le self made
man est une grande et c'est sur ce
vivier de rands décidément je dis
beaucoup de choses ce soir il ya
toujours un moment il ya une dérive et
on a vécu que des dérives ont gelé dis
ça parce que c'est extrêmement important
on renoue de façon supposés avec le
pacte social que au combien lieu au
sortir de la guerre et sa vrille alors
peut-être qu'il faudrait il serait temps
de nous dire plutôt que veut dire il
faut plus d'argent pour la puissance
publique il faudrait plus de mécanismes
de solidarité très bien mais on pourrait
se dire en réflexion et moi voyez bien
je suis de ceux de ce côté là puisque
jamais c'est ce modèle politique de
l'individualisme libéral de
l'individualisme démocratique qu'il faut
remettre en cause au profit probablement
de dispositifs mais plus que jamais dans
nos vies nos vieilles intime collectif
sur le terrain ovi fondé sur la
solidarité l'entraînent et je termine
sur ça la puissance d'invités vip
d'inventivité collective sur le terrain
de délibération de concertation les add
on avait parlé dernière fois mais de
conflit tout ça ne n'est pas dénué de
conflit mais c'est un autre type de
conflit je le redis pour arriver à des
accords sur d'autres bases politiques
formidable alors là contrairement à la
dernière fois
j'ai préparé quelque chose parce que je
me suis dit à la fois j'ai répondu
spontanément je n'y avais répondu
orwell jacques ellul et un arendt qui
sont des sacrés référence n'est ce pas
d'aujourd'hui j'ai préparé et ça
s'articule il ya une petite narration ça
va prendre que quelques instants j'ai
relu pendant le confinement ce livre
magnifique mais magnifique parce que
j'ai parlé politique du témoignage et au
moment où je travaillais sur politique
des témoignages qui constitue la
conclusion mon bouquin pour une
politique d'une impérieuse politique des
témoignages il se trouve que par le plus
grand hasard de l'existence pendant le
confinement j'ai relu parce que tu as
vécu le confinement je l'aï bien vécu
ouais très bien ça changeait potes tous
les jours avec moi je suis confiné toute
l'année à part quand je verrai
en étant confiné je gagne 0 centime
c'est pour revenir à la balance de tout
à l'heure peu importe j'ai rien contre
eux ce monsieur
chaque travail mérite salaire dit tant
qu'on ne laisse pas les autres
malsain non mais c'est que je trouve pas
ça du tout conviviale quoi que 3000 que
france télécom mp3 1000 euros
franchement ça pourrait être 5000 aussi
ça m'irait toute personne n'est lésé
alors écoutez bien sarkozy ouais et
laurent à l'excellente aussi combien il
prendre un bol un peu importe
j'ai bien vécu d'abord parce que j'étais
dans des bonnes conditions c'est très
bien le nombre de pays notamment l'est
bongo un des errances dont nous avons
parlé bon c'est pas l'enjeu là tu me
parles des livres ont été enfermées chez
toi j'étais enfermée chez moi t'as pas
de balkh ou
non mais on était très bien j'adore
appartement ma compagne un grand
appartement que j'ai des voisins
bruyants et j'ai eu la chance de et
franchement on était très bien j'étais
très calme très bien et mes aînés on
entendait un toutes les difficultés
cette suffocation de la proximité voire
la promiscuité continuelle surtout pour
les défavorisés ainsi on a bien vu que
tout le monde n'a pas vécu a conduit les
inégalités à ceux vécus pense tout ça en
laisse et parker va pas tu m'as parlé de
livres là donc je pars du dip par le
plus grand hasard de d'existence
pardon mais vraiment le plus grand
hasard quand je suis parti de chez moi
je suis allé dans un appartement de mac
ont perdu par mener des campagnes quand
même très joli appartement
pendant quelque temps
j'ai pris un lot de bouquins et souvent
on dit tu sais j'ai relu ça fait chic
des gens comme ça on en parle c'était un
déshonneur de dire j'ai lu non j'ai relu
parce que je l'avais lu à 15 ans mais
j'ai relu ce livre extraordinaire il n'y
a pas que mon livre comme quoi je suis
pas que la promo de mon lit le quai des
vigatanes d'horloge
années 30 allez voir dans les mines la
de tous les discours ou des choses
cachées occulter les conditions
d'existence des mineurs conditions de
d'habitation conditions de vie ce qui
l'avait déjà fait dans la dèche à paris
ferry qui naviguait absolument
remarquable donc une fois encore orwell
dans ton sur lequel on reviendra jamais
je me calme revient jamais ce grand
homme qui a écrit qui a écrit et qui a
et qui politiquement on appelait camp
appelait à la responsabilisation
qui devient le témoignage voilà un
auteur qui a fait un témoignage qui nous
raconte pas des soarns je pense dans
l'articulation
tu me disais tu es très inquiet on a
besoin d'espérance quand je parle de
d'être en détresse collective
dépression collective
il ya un livre magnifique d'ernest bloch
s'appelle le principe espérance qu il a
écrit entre les années fin des 45 48
début des années 50 où il parle des
utopies des utopies comme capacité de
nos imaginaires qui fait le lien avec ce
qu'on est là à envisager
d'autres possibles à nous donner la
chance liberté la joie d'envisager
d'autres
le mode d'existence possible à l'égard
de ceux qui conduisaient les
supplications continuelle l'unité
marxiste qui est un sport de marque si
sa nouvelle école non autoritaire enfin
c'est j'ai envie de dire soviétisme non
autoritaire que le marxisme et pas
autorité en ce sens en france au 25 juin
le principe espérance dans ce bloc c'est
à dire comment le pouvoir d imagination
peut être l'occasion de à la fois de de
nous donner de l'espoir pour d'autres
horizons mais a essayé de je reviens mon
histoire de les traduire dans la praxis
et le troisième dans sa fille
articulations parce que là j'ai prévu
les choses je parlais de lui tout à
l'heure de john dewey grand philosophe
qui a re découvert aujourd'hui je pense
aux livres le public et ses problèmes ou
là il fait le lien avec finalement avec
l'inde bloc avec avec orwell pierre
témoignages des gars de la société
plaies de la société on se donne la
liberté la joie l'espérance d'envisager
les choses autrement et le public et ses
problèmes c'est l'idée que la démocratie
ce n'est pas seulement le gouvernement
c'est pas des gouvernements des jeux des
procédures de gouvernementalité
pyramidale des jeux de pouvoir qui
s'impose aux citoyens une fois les
procédures élémentaires de démocratie
réaliser c'est l'expérimentation il a
beaucoup insisté sur l'expérimentation
et je crois que là c'est un enjeu majeur
et là il ya trois leçons de ces trois
livres c'est pour ça que j'ai dit je
suis un peu réfléchi hier en disant
qu'elle lit témoignage oral vie gan
lequel vit gagnent un peu se donner
des raisons d'espérer comme indiquant
que puis-je espérer dans ce monde-ci
noiret et cosider paulhe bientôt presque
vide où on va on le sait très bien de
tous assisté à des catastrophes et des
ménages dans les rues et des faillites
et des lots de licenciement et des
souffrances donc espérer espérer en
mettant actions en actions l'imagination
l'imagination de chacun d'entre nous et
et collectives dans la praxis et john
dit ouais ça s'articule dans
l'expérimentation dans la démocratie
radicale dans la démocratie sur le
terrain en vue de faire en sorte que nos
convictions nos souhaits ne génère pas
que du ressentiment et la tristesse mais
ne donne à la fois
l'espérance que ce qu'est ce qu'on a
vécu est bien et rectifier
confirme la possibilité de penser
autrement la validation d'essayer de
penser autrement activement et la valeur
de l'action sur le terrain concret de
nos vies quotidiennes une fois de plus
avant avant de poser là
le conseil pour les jeunes générations
tenons un conseil pour la génération
j'ai une question qui vous pourriez qui
m'a fait rigoler
question on applique la méthode corse
point d'interrogation ou va se coucher
alors qu'on précise j'ai un peu compris
mais qu'on me précise que serait la
méthode quand j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
des coûts qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
méthode quand j'ai compris il ya des
coups de fusil l'alleud qu'est ce que ça
veut dire leur état de cause tu veux
m'expliquer ce cas moi j'ai à peu près
s'est pas expliqué me christian on peut
comprendre si c'est un cliché de la
corse alors il faut faire attention il
ya des signes quand il ya des grands de
la communauté encore oui c'est sûr ou
des reçus ou plus si on entend corse par
par le saccage je sais pas comment le
comprendre quand ce ne se cache pas là
mais c'est quoi mais j'essaie de
comprendre il faut comment alors voilà
il faut qu'on me dit il lui demandera la
prochaine fois que je faisais des choses
il avait un taux de black blocks et une
méthode j'en parle dans mon livre de ça
parle de ça ces méthodes ou peint alors
âgé travailler sur ça j'en parle je vais
dire donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas
l'opinion logist pas que je réfléchisse
comprenez pourquoi je vais pas sur les
plateaux moi ce sur quoi j'ai pas
réfléchi je parle pas je n'en parle pas
un notre dame qui brûlent geocam avis
sur l'idée mois sur la question mais
aucun les inondations dans le sud je
n'ai aucune opinion sur la fermer aucune
je n'en pense rien peut-être dans deux
jours une fois avoir travaillé si on le
demande dans les black block j ai
réfléchi corse égale violences plus
intimidations voire là on a compris qu'à
une certaine corse un bon ok on va le
prendre tel quel on peut mettre en
critique la notion parce que
c'est un voilà on va pas brosse à
reluire mais c'est un grand peuple un
grand deal un magnifique pays est plein
de personnes aussi plein de conviction
et puis bon minutes il ya eu des buts
politiques et pour certaines très
légitime on va parler de la corse là
mais la question c'était les black
blocks moi j'ai réfléchi parce qu'il ya
un chapitre de mon livre qui s'appelle
le temps des légitime violence entre
guillemets
les black blocks tu veux que je le lis
cette phrase ou c'est trop long
si je la trouve tout de suite mais ça
prendra une seconde en une seconde une
seconde bien voilà je tombe dessus c'est
génial mais en une seconde tu es
d'accord sky ou non mais
alors je dis que voilà on est dans leur
des par exemple les black blocks ceux
qui sont dans les black blocks ils font
parler leur souffrance la plupart n'est
ce pas leur souffrance
elles sont légitimes afin par exemple on
les comprend ou non oui
traduction politique du black block
moi je vais dit
aujourd'hui c'est comme si
l'insurrection en terminant
intermittente ne recherchait au fond
qu'à assouvir sans lendemain
tendez désir de vengeance que de
jouissance ces expressions de fureur en
affirmant ouvertement aucun principe
d'espérance tiens tiens j'ai pas terminé
on fait référence en lien directe à ce
que je viens de dire à l'instar des
black blocs qui lors des défilés
s'échauffent sur les contre allées à
saccager le faucon faut dire jusqu'au
bout alors à saccager à tout va comme
s'ils se signale élan à la marge mais
dans une pleine vérité un nihilisme sans
retour seul à même de témoigner sans
fard de tous les dérèglements de
l'époque et je terminerai par cette
phrase car plus l'insatisfaction des
corps contre les institutions et les
personnes plus elle s'enferme dans des
voies sans issue je vois immanquablement
confrontés à l'échec de conduisant au
bout du compte de façon tragique de
façon tragique et comme dans une boucle
sans fin qui a alimenté les rancoeurs et
la rage
donc tu comprends bien quand tu poses la
question des black blocks nous sommes
dans pas seulement l'esthétisme de
l'insurrection qui a été encouragé
notamment par les livres du comité
invisible
cette rage et rancoeur voire la haine
this un mini festival à la marge sur les
contres arrêt contre alim dans une
planète dans une pleine vérité
la question je reviens à mon dada sky
une fois de plus si les black blocks
parce que tu m'as tu vas me posais une
question dans quelques instants d'après
ce que j'ai compris c'est pour allart tu
veux que je réponde en faisant le lien
là oui mais en tous les cas si les black
blocks et et nous tous à différents
niveaux
nous nous arrivions je les dis sa
dernière fois que je lui ai dit comme ça
mais on a terminé la
traduire nos rockeurs ne ressentiment
notre trop plein ce moment dont je vais
parler de d'extrême saturation qui a
besoin mais on a presque envie que c'est
naturel c'est pour ça qu'il faut
entendre il faut comprendre la nature
des violences contre un moment la
violence allait natural aller à aller
plus que compréhensive plus
compréhensibles par dont elle le elle
allait j'ai presque envie de dire tant
que c'est pas sur les personnes donc ça
crée pas des meurtres franchement si
c'est sur les trucs de chanel pendant le
week-end c'est pas très grave elle
témoigne elle témoigne d'un trop plein
on va pas casser des magasins chanel
pendant des années non ça mais nous ça
sa manade raidissement traduire la
traduction politique c'est ce qui est
plus dur comme une autre chose qui est
le plus dur traduire les ressentiments
je crois qu'un livre de cynthia fleury
qui me semble intéressant qui vient de
sortir sur sa si j'ai la main sur leurs
sentiments mais elle elle prend plus
d'un point de vue psychanalytique
traduire prolonger une ressentiment par
l'action politique que par l'action
positive et politique c'est ce qui est
plus dur dans la vie mais c'est notre
responsabilité c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
dur un autre conseil pour les jeunes
générations
c'est en lien direct avec ce que j'ai
dit nous avons souffert
dans le taxi qui m'a amené ici très
gentil nous avons parlé des étudiants
l'université des jeunes de 20 ans
aujourd'hui qui dans leurs piquets ont
vécu charlie les attentats le bataclan
maintenant l'université visionnement
collectif
quelqu'un m'a dit des étudiants qui
arrivent en première année tu te
souviens toi moi on a tous vécu un peu
timide on connais personne on vient
notre province peu m'a pas parlé il ya
le mas ça se fait par écran il ya une
jeunesse là puisque tu parles de jeunes
générations il ya une jeunesse
désorientée d oeuvre est marquée par la
tristesse on peut comprendre la volonté
de renouer les liens avec tous les
rassemblement qui a eu cet été ô combien
c'est pour ça au combien il ya une
jeunesse fracassé donc moi j'ai envie de
dire
reprenons tout le fil de ce que j'ai dit
là puisque nous avons énoncé parce que
j'ai dit là on pourrait presque entendre
ce que j'ai dit au delà de moi-même mais
au delà de moi-même ça que je parle de
diagnostic pas l'opinion logique puisque
vous pensez de me joindre sans fil de ce
qu'on pense analysions constatons les
choses ça que foucault disait la notion
de diagnostic est extrêmement important
le diagnostic que j'ai fait là au delà
de moi même au delà de mes impressions
je diagnostique là
d'où le faisons et à la jeune génération
elle le vit en plein ce diagnostic la
violence de ce diagnostic donc la
violence de ce diagnostic
j'ai envie de dire pression sur les
générations précédentes
pour que
elles prennent toute la responsabilité
de tout ce qui s'est passé pendant des
générations
mais aussi aussi pas seulement faire des
graves climat tout à fait relative enfin
bon mais aussi pour que l imagine et il
y à quelque chose comme ça il ya des
mouvements qui monte il ya plein de gens
qui se mettent à travailler qui vivent
des modèles qui est quoi j'ai fait
toutes ses études pour rien qu'ils se
mettent à aller dans les régions
envisager des modalités d'existence ont
ils parlé des add en conclusion de notre
dernier entretien je crois qu'il faut
plutôt que nous laisser aller à
l'isolément collectif et à la télé
socialité généralisée plus que jamais
faire liens retrouvés amitié entre
chacun de nous pour les jeunes mais pour
nous tous c'est à mon sens à mon sens le
seul motif d'espérance daoud des
perspectives mais de joie aussi possible
de jouer à ça veut dire
de s'y retrouver dans l'action pas
seulement seul avec l'action de
construire positivement et de se dire
voilà on se donne comme on peut on sait
pas on ira mais des moyens des moyens de
modifier à l'opposé de tout ce qu'on a
vécu de ce que nous vivons
vertueusement les choses eric sadin
merci merci à vous
[Musique]
com